Elon Musk has responded to the report
from Project Veritas showing a Twitter
senior engineer saying that the the
platform is biased they do censor
conservatives they don't censor the left
the company is Kami as F and the best
part is the engineer says he works like
four hours per week and just shows up
when he feels like it or just takes days
off I'm sure your new boss potentially
coming in would love to know about how
you guys don't do any work
I'm willing to bet elon's going to go to
his investors and these other you know
stockholders and people giving a loan
and whatever and be like I'm pretty sure
I can save you a lot of money because
these guys are getting paid to do
nothing we also have another release
from Project veritas
who who was the the guy at Twitter what
was his position I want to make sure I
get it right lead engineer lead engineer
saying basically get what go broke so
you've got a guy at Twitter saying
wokeness is hurting their ability to
become profitable or to be to generate
profit and uh he is absolutely correct
we'll talk about that of course the
other stuff with uh with Elon Musk
basically freezing the deal because he
wants evidence of uh the Bots proof
there's a less than five percent and
he's even called in the SEC informally
to investigate you're gonna yeah I gotta
ask was this guy who was saying he only
works four hours a week was he on a date
yeah so that that's a very weird thing
to brag about it yeah I'm super lazy I'm
not a productive person my bit on this
was you know when I was seeing the leak
the Veritas does this all the time where
they have women go on Tinder dates
there's got to be a short film or we got
to do a skit yeah where it's an engineer
you know and and she's like tell me more
and then you know like someone texts him
and it's like you you're being sustained
by Veritas and he confronts her and he's
like is this all I was to you she's like
no when it started it was but not
something more exactly it's a natural Mr
deed story yeah yes and then he's and
then she's like I don't want to do this
with Veritas I want to be with you I
don't know if I can trust you you know
then they get together in the end James
O'Keefe is the villain he's got a
twirling a mustache she's like no no I'm
against love all right we're going to
talk about news I guess
um we got Jordan Peterson getting
roasted because he he called there's a
fat chick on the cover of Sports
Illustrated and he said she was not
beautiful and it was authoritarian and
there's a look uh I think what are you
trying to say you got wisdom in choosing
your battles or something oh yeah I was
just gonna say I mean yeah pick your
battles kind of thing I I you know I'm
fan of of the doctor I want to start
only calling fat girls authoritarian now
if you're fat all right
um I don't even know what the rest of
them we have other news apparently some
other stuff yeah Joe Biden did something
yeah he's criticizing Tucker Carlson
we'll see we got we we got a lot of Elon
stuff oh yeah gas prices uh a gas
station I think in the Pacific Northwest
ran out of gas and they're preparing for
four-digit gasoline prices so uh thanks
Joe Biden joining us to talk about all
this is Jamie killstein hey everybody
who are you uh I am just here trying not
to get canceled again I I'm a wrong
place
no you guys you guys are beloved by
everybody that's what I was that's what
my PR is well not Lydia but the rest of
us definitely she's the one getting us
canceled yeah Lydia is so likable uh uh
I'm a comedian uh I'm a comedian I'm a
comic let's just say that that's much
easier than my [ __ ] sad story I
already blew it I already blew it
three minutes in so we're good yeah
actually the role on YouTube is you
can't swear in the first 30 seconds yeah
oh is that it yeah like if you swear a
lot they start pinging you yeah but the
rule specifically is like did you swear
in the first 30 seconds no all right
let's go yeah so it's like it's like all
right you know good but there are
children watching sorry well I mean I
assume we have we have we have people
who are parents will like play the show
in their car or something I love the
idea of a child with a project Veritas
shirt who doesn't want to hear dirty
words
uh we also have uh Sheamus yeah Sheamus
of Freedom Tunes we're gonna be
releasing a new cartoon this Thursday as
we every Thursday announced last show
that we're going to be launching a
paywall at freedomtunes.com if you guys
want to sign up to get notified when we
launch on May 30th for five bucks a
month you're gonna get behind the scenes
content and also an extra video every
week an extra cartoon every week oh
that's what I was supposed to do promote
my stuff
I'm so used to doing podcasts where I'm
in trouble like back in the day I would
just get introduced as hey funny man
you've seen him on Conan O'Brien and now
there's like a five minute intro like
once a darling of the left until things
got dark yeah I host a podcast let's
call the [ __ ] up it's called a f UPS
Guide to the universe
so bad at marketing uh f up sky to the
universe uh we have everyone from porn
stars to John Cleese and I talk about uh
being a screw-up and and getting through
it and uh tell you not to kill yourself
and it's great so so the interesting
thing is one of the big stories we have
is that Elon Musk announced he's voting
Republican he's he's not going to be
voting Democrat and there's there's a
there's an interesting uh story there
for for I mean obviously for many of you
for me personally for those of us who
feel like the Democrats have gone nuts
but uh you got canceled by a lot in the
left so we'll get into all that stuff
but I think your experience will will
play into the story pretty interesting
though yeah uh did you already mention I
did not introduce myself I am also here
I'm pushing buttons in the corner I'm
stoked for tonight I think it's gonna be
hilarious I'm really interested to talk
about this lady I don't think this is in
any way authoritarian but we will get
into it before we get started head over
to timcast.com and become a member if
you would like to support our work as a
member you get access to timcast IRL
podcast segments they go up at 11 PM
Monday through Thursday you are
supporting all of our journalists and
we've hired several more and we are are
currently interviewing more and hiring
more if you like the work we do you
think we do a good job please help us
expand the mission we're launching new
shows we've got a bunch of crazy new
ideas but you're also supporting
infrastructure because as I've mentioned
50 billion times by now we use rumbles
Cloud infrastructure it's a new service
it is more resilient to censorship the
more that we support business that
utilize the service the more that you
guys directly support the service
more competition develops it weakens
Silicon Valley censorship it allows
these ideas and these conversations to
exist support our work if you believe in
that mission but don't forget to smash
the like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends let's
jump into the first story yo this is
cool Elon Musk finally responds to
project Veritas sting in which Twitter
engineer says all workers there are
commie as F and that they hate the
billionaire Tesla boss he said is this
legit
that's it that's what he said but those
three words mean so much
in the viral uh the viral video
so actually I think they're so I post
this video it's got like six million
bits of veritas video I posted it
because it was newsworthy ends up people
are blowing it up and put putting out
like crazy and I'm like all right cool
um this guy says he only works four
hours a week I think I think he
basically says people can and like he
did I don't want to say that he always
does I don't know exactly what he's
trying to intend
um but he also talks about how the
company is just left left left left how
they all hate Elon he talks about how
the right will tolerate the left-wing
speech but the left will say if you
don't ban them we quit so Twitter
basically says okay ban the people on
the right because the people on the
right don't care all of that being
confirmed but in those three words is
this legit Elon Musk who is currently
he's currently Frozen the deal he's
delaying it saying prove your Bots
and now everyone's saying always trying
to shake them down or he's trying to get
out of the deal
I still think Elon Musk knows what he's
doing I still think he has a good
likelihood to win I think he I think
he's likely exposed fraud and with this
uh Veritas video Elon Musk may now be
able to actually renegotiate the deal
that's the big news because a lot of
people on the left are saying Elon Musk
uh for for uh was willing to forego due
diligence saying we'll do the deal as is
the contract is the contract he's right
Twitter is the apparently the Twitter
board is saying no no he's got to buy it
with this video release though Elon Musk
can be like whoa whoa wait a minute you
didn't disclose the work hours you
didn't disclose censorship or political
ideology but more so I think the work
hours in this is going to give him an
ability to try and go back at the
Twitter board
the real victim is the woman on the date
who had to hear all of this on a first
date that is a lot for us Brave women
and I gotta tell you project Veritas
journalist right
there's a meme
where it says if you are an engineer at
Twitter and a beautiful young woman
wants to know about your job it's James
O'Keefe do not say anything
I think that's the easiest way to put it
it's so funny that there's no Edward
snowden-esque leaker and literally all
you need to do is go put a hot chick in
front of a tech nerd and it's over
you've just blown the company this is
this is why
so I'm watching this leak the other day
and I feel bad for this guy yeah I mean
he doesn't seem like a bad dude he says
that he's okay with Elon buying the
company you know he's become more left
but he's you know he he doesn't seem
like a bad guy he's telling people like
this is what's happening well he's
saying it's bad for business he's it
doesn't even sound like he's being
ideological he's like this is hurting
the place I work but the sad thing is
you know he meets this this young
attractive woman on Tinder and he thinks
maybe he's finally found love but it was
James O'Keefe the whole time
I you know what we should do we should
do a skit where we get a guy talking to
beautiful young woman and then he's like
wait a minute something's off and then
he grabs her and he pulls it off James
every time like actually James it's
actually James
you they pulled the wig down and then
James he's sitting there in a suit he's
got a microphone tell me more about what
you was there in the pimp suit
I'm gonna have nightmares about that
forever
this is the sting operation it's it's
young women on Tinder and it works I
mean it's genius it's brilliant so basic
I think it's legit I think it's legit
because like man when it comes to this
stuff especially this culture where like
no one is encouraged to cultivate any
self-control when it comes to sexuality
I think a lot of young men they're like
okay this like could be a sting like
there's a probability but I'm just gonna
try anyway yeah that's why no one uh
nowadays wears condoms anymore it's just
the Whistleblower equivalent of that I
wonder if we are being arrogant and
maybe this dude what's his name uh Ciro
he might be he might be swimming in
women you know what I mean he might he
might just be kicking back with his own
pimp outfit and he's like just another
girl at seven o'clock make it quick lady
I mean he only works four hours a week
maybe he does just have a bunch of
different girlfriends I don't know that
I gotta give him I thought he was
playing her yeah maybe he's spying on
her for another organization like we
don't know maybe he's wearing it he's
trying to take down O'Keefe it's just
like a circular reign of hell can you
imagine how paranoid James O'Keefe must
be on a date he's like he's like all
right eventually this is coming I know I
know it works yeah he's just always
trying to shake them down for
microphones
so so uh he's like let's go to the beach
for our date yeah well you know we'll go
swimming yeah we'll go swimming yeah I
gotta admit I do feel bad for for a lot
of these people that get that get caught
by uh O'Keefe because I don't think
not every single person that gets
exposed is a bad guy right this guy is
just he's a senior engineer he's in this
environment he probably doesn't know or
care about what's going on culturally he
does a little bit and he's like yeah
this is what's happening
and so now
he's forced to be a whistleblower
basically like but I I still respect and
think what James is doing is completely
legitimate I mean it's real reporting
and if we can't hear what these people
are saying and doing we don't know
what's going on in these companies bad
things happen right so this guy getting
you know basically admitting everything
and he he's different from a lot of what
we've seen when we've seen like that
Google woman and she's talking about
stuff it's like you've got people at Big
tech companies talking about how they
set policy are they due policy this is a
guy in a date who's like yo that's what
my company his life isn't that crazy
right so now he's deleted his Twitter
account I think he's deleted his
LinkedIn the Twitter has issued a
statement to their tweets that's what
they that's what they call it uh that's
the most offensive yeah that's super
offended
so what is a tweet is that a customer is
that someone who works there someone who
works there so you know he didn't
mention that on the day yeah no wonder
funny he's still too ashamed of that
they call us tweets yeah it'll be funny
if he just started crying
all right so uh we have this uh the
Instagram post from Veritas targeting of
tweeps says the email tweets I believe
I'm reading that as we as we expected a
video is posted this evening by project
Veritas depicting a tweep allegedly
speaking about a number of company
issues we're in contact with the person
involved in doing everything we can to
help them there may be more videos to
come and we're continuing to monitor the
situation help them help him you mean
why are they saying them them there are
we learning something about syrup yeah
well but all right is it not a little
bit interesting that everyone at Twitter
who didn't like Elon Musk felt very
comfortable voicing their displeasure
with him potentially taking over the
company even though he may have been
running the place uh in the near future
but someone who has issues with the way
Twitter is run now tries to be very
quiet and the only way we're able to get
information from them is on hidden
camera right right right it goes on it
says please review my previous note on
how you can protect yourself and your
fellow tweets from similar attempts in
the future if you think you are being
targeted or have been targeted contact
blank at twitter.com redacted for safety
and privacy of those involved we ask you
do not tweet about the situation or any
related issues please remember that we
all have an obligation to protect
confidential proprietary information and
not discuss internal conversations
policies or products outside of work
take care and stay safe pat pat as soon
as you sent the email out they leaked it
to project Veritas so that last message
right there fell on deaf ears for sure
whoopsie oh good though I mean zero may
not be somebody who's stepping up and
willing to speak out about the what I
view as corruption within the company
somebody is somebody somebody you know
is is showing what they're saying behind
the scenes and exposing what I would
view as malfeasance also are there any
hot blondes that can go undercover and
find out why I'm Shadow banned on
Instagram there you go can we just start
like just hiring our own hot girls to
find out I'm imagining the same scenario
with like a hot young girl talking to
Mark Zuckerberg and how he would be no
idea to respond yeah he would just be
like like staring at her blankly yeah
tell me about your work my work is good
it's like
[Laughter]
what's happening no I don't know uh
Zuckerberg's married I think right oh
yeah
I do always think it's stupid that
people try and do these arguments where
it's like if for some reason they don't
like you they attack your manhood yeah
but primarily on the left I always find
that funny yeah like why is it that
people on the left who are the ones who
are like traditional masculinity isn't a
thing and then they're like you're an
incel it's like okay well because one
thing the left because everyone don't
believe well exactly left doesn't
believe the things that they espouse
they know that conservatives are
generally more sensitive to the idea of
whether or not they're being considered
masculine or at least they assume that
they're constantly trying to like break
down gender barriers but they think oh
if I challenge his manhood then I'll be
able to manipulate him into doing what I
want everyone has the same fears
everyone has the same insecurities
everyone's a hypocrite everyone uses the
same stuff except for this guy
like it's it's like they go after Ben
Shapiro first of all they I I've heard
over and over how short Ben Shapiro is
yeah then we go and meet him and he's
not sure normal like average taller than
all of us he was like six seven six six
three another live from the liberal one
yeah
did he just dunks on all of us like
literally they they actually built an
oversized set because they want you no
no I think he's like a slightly about
average yeah and I was like oh he's
already sick he's taller than me great
there you go yeah yeah yeah you didn't
you didn't have to tell people that like
they all know but they like they lie
about his height yeah and then they also
call him an incel and Ben's just sitting
there with his kids and his wife and
he's like I have a family and then
you're like I don't understand why who
are they trying to hurt yeah go after
ideas go after ideas that's all you have
to do if you have any Merit to yours go
after ideas like any time I was it's
like when you're fighting with your
girlfriend or boyfriend and the second
you realize you're wrong you just like
change the subject and panic
the last week and it's just you're
panicking you're doubling down and
you're panicking and you're you're short
all right Bud you're out of ideas
yeah no it's true there are so many it's
funny because you bring up relationships
there are so many different
communication habits that you see
predominantly on the left that would be
deeply unhealthy in any kind of
relationship so for example they assume
that they know that you have some kind
of like racist attitude inside of you or
sexist attitude and then they're just
like trying to pick at your words in
some way that'll justify their narrative
they like start with the conclusion that
you're a bad person acting in bad faith
so they can malign that's not how you
have conversations with people that's
not how you have conversations with
people it's deeply unhealthy that's why
I was saying the other day when we had
mad on I was like we don't do uh we
don't do uh stuntmen right political
stunt man people who do make games of
things and they're like infotainment
stuff I'm not going to invite them on I
mean maybe but people who have done it
to us are just like out the first time
they do it yeah so if they if they try
and pull any stunts to rage bait Their
audience and go ooh look at us we're
culture Wares I'm like yeah we're not
gonna hide that guy uh all right we have
we have a correction we have a story
from uh Veritas but the we mentioned
earlier that the guy was a lead engineer
he's like oh my fault but let's read
this story with a tweet from Lydia
Lederman oh who's this who is that
leiterman yes I pronounce it wrong yeah
Twitter lead client partner says woke
ideology responsible for inability to
profit
affirm's Twitter not here to give people
free speech refuses taking Elon Musk
seriously due to Asperger's making him
special there we go well now here's the
issue I like the first thing he said but
the ableism just gets to me it is
problematic
Let's uh let's hear what this man has to
say
also is this another date I think so yes
yeah this is how you do it well to be
fair guys probably make pretty good
money so it's probably pretty easy for
them to get dates sure I mean look if
you're a guy on Tinder you know you're
right I got very excited when you said
wmd is I'm like finally what I'm allowed
to agree with I agree with that one
don't get me in trouble I remember that
I remember the war in Iraq it's bad
follow me on Twitter
so this guy my favorite by the way was
during that kind of slurred rant seeing
the person he was out with slowly pick
up the wine glass as he's just rambling
what did you notice I also one thing I
love to do the way he said
he said oh people can
come Solutions like okay great pretty
much so uh I noticed something
did you notice something about this
video that is different from the other
video I don't think you saw the other
video though
was it it's a dude right it's a dude
that means it's not Tinder that means
it's
grinder it's a grinder date spicy
Advertiser as my business is what I do
every day and why I go out is like we
want it to be as
fair and transparent and accurate as
possible yeah and if that means there
there's a level of censorship to make it
correct quote unquote again and what
does correct mean I guess like it's just
kind of goes into the idea of like well
what is correct if we're implementing
all these rules that there's and Elon
wants to dismantle them then technically
our ideology has led us to not making
money because we're not making money and
Elon wants to turn it the other way so
that we can make money there's a
statement they need all 7 000 people to
say and so they can't like tell us the
bike
so
I can't even take what you're saying
seriously targeting of types wait wait
you're gonna read it let me see you're
getting how to protect yourself
groups like project Veritas are actors
oh he's so cool I'm sorry at that second
I would end the date I'm like uh okay oh
you don't know how to pronounce Veritas
no no no 100 you know what that's the
Veritas journalist no I know I know
that's what I'm saying it's it's the
police obviously
he's like what's this project
he's like I've never heard of this
wonderful sounding organization why does
Twitter dislike them jams
wait wait wait hold on let me go back a
little bit he starts talking about it is
that it's like some group that's trying
to just out the employees like they're
trying to yo this is free this is from
like yesterday bro this is like how
obvious does a trap have to be yeah
project Veritas he's like let me tell
you everything I think about you know
what I love Acorn yeah hey it's like
he's like this wonderful organization
Acorn they got destroyed I mean this
person this is the ultimate if you are
doing a sting operation and your mark
shows you your other successful sting
operation here it's just gold you're
like
dating coaches who are telling people to
repeat every incriminating thing about
themselves on their first date with a
stranger wait is this a big thing no I'm
I'm being sorry I have no idea no
because I've definitely done that on
Thursdays where I was just like sit down
and let me tell you A Tale of a website
called Jezebel uh I've done that on
Thursdays so it's like do not suggest
yeah the Twitter guy sits down and he's
like oh hello I'm John uh and you're
Janet nice to meet you I commit crimes
at Twitter I disparage people who are
lesser than me and I want to rule the
world and that's our goal for the
company and we're going to steal money
from people it's like well that was
something weird to lead with all right
let's play more like this record them
and then go sell it to the New York
Times and say this is what the Twitter
I'm playing to say this is what's really
happening this is what they're telling
us you're lucky that you met me
organically because I would be
questioning everything about him
oh they just put that in there to hurt
the man oh they just put that in there
to hurt them there was no reason to
include that in the story dude that's a
cartoon that didn't really happen no
none of that really happened to the
camera we are being set up right now
camera Tim this is the someone reporting
misinformation exactly we're not
following further right now we are going
on record it's a trap it's a trap it's a
trap this is the skit this is not real
met you at a bar how could you do this
to me I didn't mean to he's like the
news you're not part of that project
Veritas you would never hurt me this is
ridiculous dude uh we I'll tell you
we're about to hear sirens the house is
being surrounded right now this is us
being set up right one million percent
no they're they're like filming us I
don't know through the computer some oh
my gosh we have webcams on our computer
we're being set up they want to see your
response to it let me play this let me
play it again you're lucky that you met
me organically because I would be
questioning everything about you
I know it's like very creepy like he
gets real close to him
yeah he knows do you guys think he knew
I mean it looks like it but he or but he
said everything he wasn't supposed to
say right yeah but he literally looked
into yeah but this guy's suspicious of
project Veritas and he goes on a date
and tells the person and shows them the
email shows them to do it I don't know I
got to tell you guys the story I once
worked for a news organization
and uh we're getting spear phishing
emails
so do you guys know what spear fishing
is like the actual sport or is it some
weird political it's a hacker term yep
see I know it so uh phishing is when
you'll get a random email that says like
um sign up today click here yeah you do
and then it tries to get you give your
password a spear phishing attack is when
they spoof an email
and so we were getting emails from
higher-ups at this company to us saying
hey there's a big story check it out
right here and I'm not an idiot so as
soon as I saw it I laughed it had like
the wrong title for the for the for the
staff member I brought it to the CTO and
I was like Hey we're getting phishing
attempts I was like maybe it's just me
and he was like no everybody got it and
I was like oh for real he's like and 25
people clicked it oh my God and I went I
was like yeah and then I was like didn't
they realize their boss wasn't that
position and they were like they didn't
think about it and so
they locked it up right away yeah here's
where it gets really good
so then a few days later we all get
basic phishing attacks where it's an
email from a company that shouldn't that
I've never heard of and it's like sign
up today click here and I laugh and so I
go to the CTO again and I say I'm
getting more phishing attempts and he's
like I know I know I know we'll we'll
deal with it and then a few hours later
a company-wide email from the CTO goes
out saying guys I told you not to click
these links you if you've clicked any of
these links you now need to reset your
password
with a link
and and as soon as I saw it I went to
the CTO and I was like bro this was the
best spear fishing attack ever that's
incredible the CTO never sent out an
email that was the attack clever and
then he was like wait what happened and
I was like it came from you dude they
spoofed your email they were BR it was
masterful that is and they got him oh
suicide and so here's here's why I bring
this up because hackers are hilarious it
was I was laughing and the CTO was like
he was stressed but he was like that was
good that's incredible that wasn't it
was a very clever manipulation like it
was a three-layered attack but here's
why I bring the story up for one I love
that story of like the hacker move how
they broke into the system I'm in but
the best part is this guy working for
Twitter
is sent a warning email from there
people like guys be on the lookout don't
do this and he goes I'm gonna do exactly
what they told me not to do with this
stranger look he's like I'm gonna get
some tail also these are not sexy
stories to talk about on the day like if
you're getting that email just bring up
something else dude I'd like to issue an
apology and retraction it was not a
grinder date oh no
organic right dude I can't grinder HQ
yeah
I can't wait to finally see the Veritas
video where it's like at the altar at
their wedding he's like yeah he's just
going on about his job and the corrupt
things
like look at this crazy look at this
email like it's their 25th wedding
anniversary the priest is like uh we
will now have the bride and groom read
their vows and then he's like when I
first met you I was working for a large
bank I was funneling money to private
corporations oh my gosh no dude and the
priest is like he's a fake priest he's
also in and out he's like if you have
any intimidating information about
yourself you may now say it her children
from a past marriage have tiny mustaches
and they're wearing trench coats
yo we got it we have to get we have to
do the skit we have to get James in on
it we have to like we get like a small
young woman sitting in front of the guy
and he goes wait a minute and when he
grabs her hair and pulls it down it's
just a full like six foot tall James
O'Keefe in a suit this is like the
Twitter version of To Catch a Predator
where every time they're like I'm Gonna
Get Away you're not from that crazy
MSNBC show and then Chris Hanson what we
do that with James O'Keefe like why
don't you have a seat why don't you take
a seat over there what part of you
thought this made any sense
dude uh I'm not kidding we should legit
do those that'd be funny my legit advice
by the way when you're out on dates ask
about the other person yeah no seriously
they're like dogs so these these caught
monologuing which we know is not
something insufferable exactly for a
first date I gotta say too I genuinely
think this guy knew what was up he saw
that email he's like here's a guy I'm
gonna meet him in a bar tell him that we
did no fill in the head still weird
right yeah yeah but if you met someone
randomly you wouldn't think it but he
just got that email he is a tweet also
some of these people are just sociopaths
they're just narcissists where they're
like yeah I'm picking up people randomly
I don't have anything to worry about
blah blah blah instead of I mean meeting
organically is almost more suspect than
Tinder because Tinder there are so many
options so many options I mean
essentially this dude just walks up to
you I mean that's you were targeted that
that to me is easier to spot do you
think so do you think that Veritas has
like a dossier on the Twitter employees
and so they send out like a young dude
to this bar and they're like your target
is this man when he pulls up the
photograph and he's like yeah like I'm
gonna go into this type like look up
like x's on Facebook book and stuff and
then he shows up in Project veritas this
sounds very fun it does sound fun
doesn't it like I'm I until you have to
break their heart oh yeah you guys think
this is a laughing matter no I would
fall in love that's why I fall in love
with myself you've already written two
really funny events we should do one is
where it's like the the the teen drama
where the jock dates the ugly girl
because he was dared to do it that's
great it's like I want to remember it's
become something else but then the other
one is the sting goes all the way to
like to marriage that no I wanted to go
further like I would do it like it
starts with them getting married and
then there's like the next thing is a
guy's 25th wedding anniversary the next
one is like in the hospital dying with
his wife he's been married to his entire
life after that is like both of them
strangely periodically there's a there's
different men like doing work and
they're all James O'Keefe like one day
they're like the milkman
[Laughter]
just gonna just gonna fix the cable here
and he's just like positioning his his
jacket he's like literally setting up
cameras like no it's the cable it's for
the cable dead I'm not kidding we should
legit do it all right one million
percent I will stay another day to film
this let's let's
we gotta have James fly out so here's
another story this is this is more
political it's kind of crazy it's Elon
Musk again news reports Elon Musk says
he'll vote Republican for the first time
in the next election
uh Elon Musk one of us uh what's it
Google gobble Google gobble Elon Musk if
I see him shortly I will tell him Google
gobble yes uh do you guys know the
reference it's from a really old movie
freaks yeah where the the woman is like
at the table and all the people are
going Google one of us so uh Elon Musk
uh he basically said I've voted
overwhelmingly for Democrats
historically like I'm not sure I might
never have voted for a republican just
to be clear now this election I will
Newsweek says they're not sure if it's
the midterms the 21 2024 presidential
election which is a weird thing to add
considering he said the next election
which is literally the midterms but sure
whatever Elon Musk has continually been
posting memes about either the left
losing the middle the left going too far
left
or of him being like yo I'm a moderate
and this doesn't speak to me and things
like that it's it's interesting now
I tweeted maybe the left should stop and
reflect on why they're losing so many
people
they won't do it the responses I got
or people saying like uh the ultra rich
guy who doesn't want to pay taxes no no
of course he wants to be a republican
that's why all the billionaires are
constantly promoting right-wing policy
real quick since 2012 as we've covered
on the show extensively Democrats have
been the party of the wealthy it's been
reiterated in 2021 with more data
showing higher income earners on our
line with the Democratic party Elon Musk
just paid more taxes than anyone's ever
paid in history and why didn't he vote
four years ago Republican when he was
already when he's still a billionaire
I've seen everyone from my broke Jiu
Jitsu friends to people who have health
podcasts over covid over Trump because
of the the Twitter wokeness slowly go
more and more to the right you know
people wanted me to go sort of like full
right-wing actual grifter after my
cancellation happened and I didn't do it
and so when I talk about this stuff I'm
actually talking about it from the left
I as someone who is still fairly liberal
sees the left being pushed farther and
farther away because it wasn't
Republicans who were shutting down their
businesses or gyms over covid it wasn't
um you know I have friends who they're
professional athletes and suddenly it
was Donald Trump saying to go outside
and exercise and Democrats saying if you
go for a walk you're gonna you know kill
your aunt or whatever
um although wokeness all my comedy
friends who love Dave Chappelle and even
if they don't agree with everything Dave
Chappelle says Suddenly It's the left
trying to censor censor their favorite
comedians who you know I mean God when I
was watching Chappelle in New York he
was going after Bush going after the war
in Iraq like talking about the war on
drugs like he's always been a liberal
dude
um I'm watching these people go from
disenfranchised I'm sick of the left I
guess I'm not really a Democrat maybe
I'm independent to a lot of them just
going you know what conservatives are
cooler right now I'm just gonna I'm
gonna go I did a show in Houston and
there are these three little goth kids
in the front row and they were tattooed
and they were like 21 or something and I
asked them I thought they were super
liberal I'm like what's it like being
liberal in Houston and they were like
nah if that man we're conservatives and
I was like you look like undercover
antify agents like what is happening
like yo bro watch this Prager you video
you're like what I want to go do DMT and
talk about the free market like it was
that and it's like yeah man we are
pushing these people away like I'm it
has nothing to do with privilege or
wealth like I'm talking to normal people
I've lived in Arizona and Texas the last
couple years not in Brooklyn not in Los
Angeles and yeah and and their
grievances are valid I don't know if
that would make me full conservative but
the stuff that pushed them away I don't
disagree with
are you sure are you sure they left us
pushing them away or maybe Turning Point
USA is just making really good memes
that's it I got to tell you uh so so uh
it was six months ago that I was a
hardcore socialist authoritarian uh uh
you know just absolutely and um I wore I
wore uh uniforms every day and then
Charlie Kirk smiled at me yeah that's
like a bolt of lightning oh my God it
was another James O'Keefe set up dude
why'd you let Charlie cook smile at you
like that they got you got it no this is
interesting because
um like the left is in my opinion has
gone absolutely insane and it's
exemplified in a lot of ways one I love
playing this video from the juice media
it's an old video from Twitter I briefly
thought you said from the Geo media and
I was like well here we go
this is the episode my last name is calm
down you're like I'm coming here not to
get canceled
all right well let's play it hit up the
Jew media everybody the juice they're
actually like orange they do produce a
lot of progressive stuff today but um
there's this guy Hugo ferrant I'm
probably pronouncing your name wrong
Hugo he did a thing called rap news and
rap news six is about cable gate with
Julian Assange in this in this video
they're defending the release of uh
effectively defending the release of the
cables from WikiLeaks
criticizing Hillary Clinton as the
secret Terry keeping secrets on the
public and threatening to prosecute
Assange because the Australia's in the
American Empire and they control the
stuff Alex Jones is in it screaming that
the globalist not akami Nazi fascists
are coming hell yeah so so that
depiction of of Jones is is the 10 years
ago when he was like the government is
evil and they're trying to take over now
they're claiming he is a Nazi he says in
the end they're trying to turn back the
clock on freedom of speech and so I'm
like if you praise Julian Assange
say that they're trying to turn back the
clock on freedom of speech say Hillary
Clinton is is bad or wrong and depict
Alex Jones someone fighting Nazis you
are right wing but that video was
Progressive left in 2010. now of course
you could say well that's just what
happens conservatives you know people
who are progressive eventually the whole
society culture shifts left and I'm like
no no hold on there a minute that's
that's ridiculous no that's a great
point I remember you know in my super
Progressive days being like the clintons
are tied to Goldman they're corporate
blah blah then Trump goes they're tied
to Goldman and it's like well he hates
women you know that now what Trump left
out is like well he's also part of the
swamp right like so is his team like
they're all corporate hacks however it
was it's also true like I've been saying
that about Clinton forever liberals have
been saying that about Clinton this
forever this is why I didn't vote for
Trump in 2016. I I I'm lying I don't but
I don't buy it I don't believe it I
don't care uh in his first term Trump
does a point you know I'll always just
say Bolton Warhawk was one of the worst
ideas nuts and he had to get rid of him
and Bolton betrayed him and and there
was there were several people that he
brought on but I quickly then saw that
Trump was whatever he is outside of that
establishment order he was no new Wars
he was uh pulling our troops out of the
Middle East and I was like I'll take
what I can get and if I if Biden's the
other other choice then uh you know then
I'm gonna I'm gonna vote for Trump so I
feel like Elon I feel like wow I guess
I'm gonna vote for you know this guy but
even vox.com said Trump was moderate and
I still that was back in 2016 and I
still was like I'm not going to play
this game but now you let's let's throw
wrote back to what we had last night
when Matt Bender was here
I'm uh traditionally like my political
position is is that of like a 2012
liberal Democrat you know probably not I
don't even call it moderate or Centrist
and the argument the left says is if you
have stayed the same place from where
you were 10 years ago then of course
today you're conservative because the
younger generation is is more
Progressive that's what happens right
like they say things like yeah and in
people from 1954 were like this 1964
Civil Rights Act is too much change I'm
just a regular person from 1954 and I'm
like eugenicists in the 1900s and 20s
also thought they were the future they
were not they were wrong just because
you have ideas doesn't mean they're the
future you could be wrong so I'll I'll
say this to the Elon thing I thought it
was absolutely fascinating that we had
on a progressive who was arguing with me
and my position is pro-choice
and he was like we were so far apart in
our view on abortion that he was he
believed I was conservative and Sheamus
is the conservative for a lifer dude I
think you're the problem yeah I do I
think I think he wanted you to be
pro-life more than I want you to be
pro-life I agree like the the arguments
were right and you want to do it for
babies
[Laughter]
but no yes I want I but no it's funny
because it's uh this is something you
and I have argued about like a number of
times on the show the abortion issue
yeah we've got heat like Tim is not on
the like conservative side of the issue
definitely not it's the traditional
liberal side I'm glad that you guys make
Lydia be quiet during the year I know
that's the only good thing
oh I know I follow her on Twitter
and my old woke brain is like I can't
argue with her she's a woman
yeah that's when he pulled the vote card
anytime someone tries to go after your
pro wife be like uh my body my choice
um yeah I you know and and the button
not to be too Earnest but the the the
the bummer of that is when I'm talking
to someone I mean Lydia and I were
talking about abortion because that's
how I Small Talk uh before we went on
air like downstairs and so that abortion
yeah that's it that's my first Tinder
date as there I'm speaking into
someone's microphone
um is when you have someone who is even
moderately on your side that is the time
instead of looking to pick them apart
for Twitter or whatever that's the time
to actually talk about compromise so
like Lydia and I were talking about and
and me and her are pretty far apart on
this issue but we were talking about
things we agreed with like things that
um kids should be taught like access to
contraceptions or sex ed or you know
whatever and if one side just goes you
want to kill women and the other side
just goes you want to kill babies it's
like well there's not a ton of Middle
Ground there but if you find someone who
goes you know I I'm pro-life but yeah in
the case of rape and incest like I'm
torn that's your opportunity to have a
conversation with them if you have
someone who goes I'm pro-choice but
having an abortion like man like six
months in like that seems kind of rough
right that's your chance for a pro-life
person to have a conversation and then
you guys are talking and then you can
actually come up with some sort of well
how do we stop unwanted pregnancies or
how do we work on that because that's a
solvable issue or well I think there's a
couple things not not necessarily just
like stopping unwanted pregnancies like
how do we find a home for for children
whose mothers didn't did plan the
pregnancy and then also because one
thing I would disagree with is so I
don't believe in any exceptions but Tim
and I have conversations about it pretty
frequently I do think the conversation
can be open but there has to be a belief
that like you can reason with the person
I think that's really important and
we've kind of lost that and like in some
cases it's warranted unfortunately
Sheamus has made some good points that
even in the past month I've my position
shifted it's it's not we call it the
first trimester
so so uh Sheamus mentioned I was
thinking about this earlier you were
talking about how abortion was the
intentional killing of the baby and this
was like a month or two ago and I was
like no no we're not talking about that
we're talking about if the term
pregnancy has to be ended for some
reason and then you were saying yes and
that abortion would mean killing the
baby and I said that's not true I was
wrong and then because yesterday we pull
up the CDC definition which literally
says an abortion is a termination of a
pregnancy that does not result in a live
birth
meaning if you would legalize abortion
post viability due to the risk due to
the pregnancy causing a risk to the
private patient's Health as the law read
you would be saying terminate the
pregnancy and not result in a live birth
why do that when you can just I I know I
don't want to I don't want to get into
the issue I want to just make the point
that that was sort of like a realization
for me so my so so anyway I want to take
it back to the politics because
otherwise we'll just talk about abortion
forever it was it was fascinating that
you know Matt Bender is a modern leftist
or you know Progressive what do you want
to call it we used to be buddies and
he's he's arguing with me as though I'm
not pro-choice
because he said
that he believes a woman has the right
to abort a baby at nine months
electively for any reason
and and that's what we saw with Eric
Adams recently Jen sackie I think before
she left said Joe Biden believes there
should be no restrictions we saw it with
uh with Northam we saw it with Kathy
Tran it I I read the bill from Colorado
which outright says there get this the
Colorado Bill not only says there can be
no restrictions it says a fetus embryo
or fertilized egg has no rights under
state law it gets crazier and it goes
back further than people realize in the
early 2000s Obama as a senator voted
against the born alive act yep well so
uh well would you would you say that
that is the extreme version just like
these things being floated right now
about making miscarriages a crime or a
birth control crime like would that be
the extreme on the other end or would
you not equate the two because babies
well I don't know anyone who sang a
miscarriage should be a crime I haven't
heard anyone argue that I think people
know that I think people will say that
like certain abort efficients uh should
be but I don't know that they're talking
about birth control and general or
contraceptives in general got it yeah
and I think uh
when we hear stuff like that it's it's
it's it's simple enough to be like
Sheamus do you agree with that right do
you think I don't think we're not but
the part of the problem is the whole
part of that it's like the framing
bothers me because I there's I don't
know anyone I mean I know a lot of
pro-life people I don't know anyone who
says like a miscarriage should be
paralyzed but so so here's the what the
way I see it it's like okay let's try
and have a conversation if someone is
convinced like I don't know I saw this
story I said it was true I'd be like
okay well I think that's wrong we agree
well and then I can also go oh I don't
know yeah I saw it on Twitter maybe it
wasn't you know what I mean like I was
even ashamed on a
on like a pro-life level I was sort of
ashamed that I didn't really and again
I've never said I was an abortion expert
I'm there are you know feminists and
whatever that know a lot more than me
but I
there was a part of me when I started
getting Republican friends and this I
just started rounding them up and this
came out I was so used to throwing out
my pro-choice tweets I you know had them
locked and loaded know the formula blah
blah blah called Ben Shapiro short
whatever it is an abortion is wrong then
why is Ben
and so and then suddenly my feed for the
first time in my life my Twitter feed is
like yeah well I guess I just want to
kill babies and I was like wait she's
like oh yeah I don't want to kill babies
and I literally realized that I I never
had researched like you were saying Tim
like I don't know when does it feel when
does it I I actually did not know the
answer and I think again if ever if
people were willing to go I don't know
or if someone
if pro-life people instead of just were
so used to we have to defend our stuff
we're on Twitter where we're you know
we're on the news we have to stick to
our stick to our talking point if you
can take a second to go man like even
you said you're you're not for abortion
in any cases but to take that second to
go dude I don't know what it would be
like to be a woman who was raped and to
have to give that baby the term and yeah
we should talk about it I'm not for it
but just I feel like neither side will
show empathy yes and that's what we need
to do and then we can disagree and then
we can talk but probably if we're both
showing empathy we can go okay this
person's actually a decent human who
you're doing what you think is right
right if you think you're saving babies
then I must look like a monster right if
I think I'm saving women vice versa I
gotta disagree with you on this the
right is notorious for being memed as
the debate me side right bench bear why
won't you debate me oh right right so
when if I make a YouTube video there's
there's the there's the ex there's the
um the um the rule and the exceptions if
I make a video and I'm like I believe
you know conservative policy is or I
believe policy is wrong conservatives
will comment and they'll make arguments
at me if I say policy is wrong and it
goes against the left they will call my
advertisers they'll start contacting you
know various companies I'll start
getting angry emails I'll get death
threats so when we say when you say
there's no empathy
Sheamus Sheamus and I can can disagree
on the issue you know every day and we
laugh together and we hang out together
oh no no to be clear I was saying both
sides trust me I've been canceled like I
know the left does I was saying
um these conversations are important the
fact that you disagree and you can still
make jokes about it like that is what's
important and it's weird that right I
disagree it's not both sides oh oh okay
it is it is the rule on the left and the
exception on the right the left will not
tolerate deviance the right might not
but typically we'll engage was more
likely to have a conversation with you
this is why we see the Elon Musk poll
this is why uh this is why Elon Musk
feels the way he he does it's why so
many people who watch this feel the way
they do uh I mean I can't speak to your
experience but you look at not good but
people who are you're you're on the left
and then all of a sudden they destroy
you yeah and then people on the right
are sitting there drinking a beer like
you want a beer dude like tell us what
happened yeah I mean that that is
actually what happened yeah I was gonna
say you you said you rounded up a bunch
of right-wing friends I think they
rounded you up they're like a label who
got canceled get over here I was telling
my friend the other day if I wrote a
book called from feminist to Freedom
Fighter I would be a billionaire just me
holding the flag in a giant red pill uh
I would have so much money you know I'll
I'll explain I've had enough of this
good by the way this whiskey is very
very good and so strong I take a sip and
just my body is just lit for five
minutes he knows whiskey Lauren doesn't
she put that in a paper cup no no the
only reason I'm not hammered is because
they warned me about what Lauren did and
I was like that's why it's next to my
giant water bottle
Lauren uh was just grabbed a thousand
dollar bottle of whiskey and was just
pouring it into a paper cup and drinking
it wow and then I didn't realize and I
looked over and I was like Lauren are
you pouring the Pappy in the paper cup
and she's like what's that what's this
let's be real it's kind of a flex it's a
little bit of a flex
I'm like this is this is like a special
drink I almost drank it out of a coffee
mug me and Lauren are trash people okay
so so anyway look
um well what you were saying is you know
the Lydia and I were talking about this
too which is
one of the weirdest things that happened
was I could have made money and needed
money and I didn't want to be a you know
center-right version of the pretentious
liberal that I was because that's what
got me in trouble it was being a
self-righteous loud liberal then I have
an affair and they go hahaha you're not
perfect you know that was the story any
comic on stage who did what I did who
talked about it um especially talked
about it with like regret like yeah I
wish I didn't do it it was awful
um you know no one's getting in trouble
for that but so so you you this is what
you got canceled over on the left yeah
yeah and so but in the feminist World a
consensual Affair got called sexual
misconduct consensual one-night stands
got called predatory behavior and it was
like
it's insane remember Aziz Ansari yeah he
had a bad date and she was like it was
assault and he was like whoa yeah the
Woodward and Bernstein reporting of
babe.net is that the article you were
talking about it was literally called
babe.net it was like no fact checking I
mean there was a line in the Jezebel
article written about me where it said
uh a girl a girl that I slept with sorry
a woman
um that I slept with
um
literally in the article said something
along the lines of it was the safest I
felt with a man something saying that
when I'm with women I treat them well
and then said uh but a week later he
called me a road F on his podcast and
then Jezebel in parentheses said Jezebel
could not find that quote and it's like
right because I'm not talking about
smashing Road Poon on my feminist
podcast with my wife you Psychopaths but
they still printed that and that was
enough and that headline will still come
up when people are looking for me I mean
I've had to have some people don't think
about with cancellations like I've lost
tons of gigs still this is eight years
ago I am a literally different man
um every relationship I've had uh try
explaining to elderly conservative
parents of your girlfriend what the
metoo movement is or what an open
relationship like there's just weird
stuff that will haunt you always but I I
do feel like if you're you're meeting
your girlfriend's conservative parents
for the first time yeah and you want to
explain to them cancellation you can be
like a bunch of Libs were lying about
trying to cancel me and they'll be like
we got you these feminists yeah yeah I
mean yeah yeah you know that is probably
the move I should do conservatives not
ask enough questions
what do you mean I'm giving you a hard
time because you're like yeah no I got
canceled by a bunch of liberals they're
like oh nice not like for what what
happened no no no they're gonna say I
get it yeah they're gonna say oh I know
exactly what that is like let me bang
your daughter and we'll drink these
liberal tears together because if you're
like if you Google search me there's
some bad things that come up they're
gonna go but if you say a bunch of
feminists got mad and started lying
about me they'll be like we hear you
brother yeah they're gonna be like you
poor man
and then they're gonna the father's
gonna be like I approve of this
relationship you know what that's my
go-to excuse for anything I do wrong
ever again like dude a bunch of
feminists lied about me I don't know I'm
sorry but we have a recording of you say
it now it was from feminist reporting
even with my family uh my mom's like
your your brother said that you did this
as a bunch of feminist lying about it
don't even worry about it don't even
care it's like you're at you're a trump
rally and you fart and some woman calls
you out like this is a bunch of
feminists she's a feminist and they're
like oh she's lying yes yeah you didn't
see antifa run by fart and then you jump
into the bushes it was literally an
antique super soldier so uh before the
show you were asking me like if I had a
moment where I I moved or anything like
that yeah and I was I was saying like
I'm in I'm I'm in essentially the exact
same place I've always been except for
like gun control right because I was
moderate on gun control now I'm
basically two-way absolutist and I've
even argued the Constitution guarantees
the right of an individual to have
nuclear weapons you want to change it
I'm not saying that it should it should
be that way I'm saying people had
cannons and and and frigates and and
privateers and all that stuff so for me
I didn't I didn't change but the issue
is conservatives didn't change either
everybody changed a little bit everybody
moved a little bit to the left actually
you can you can look at data from the
from the New York Times the
conservatives seemed way cooler with
like gay people right like Trump
unfurled an LGBT flag on stage like the
RNC or something did he do it daily
though I would have been the flex but he
made a point about how you know the the
guy who uh you know shot the the
nightclub he was like he's killing our
people right and and they clapped for it
they were like yes like that's wrong and
so there were a lot of uh changes that
happened uh Trump being okay with gay
marriage was it was uh
you know how a lot of people were like
okay like this is this is this is you
know Obama and Clinton weren't okay with
it right right right they got passed
because Biden like slipped up on The
View right or something like so so I'm
watching this uh this video from rap
news rap news number six
and uh pro-free Speech Pro Julian
Assange and I'm like all of these
positions right now if you watch that
you'd be a trump supporter and this was
back during occupy it was like preoccupy
Wall Street when they actually the rap
news guys filmed at Occupy Wall Street
and I'm in the video as part of a group
with Anonymous and we're like yelling
stuff because when I found out that they
were making the video I I I saw it on
their face started spitting bars I know
I was like let me in let me in like dude
I love this stuff so I'm just like an
extra in it yeah as we're all like
chanting or whatever
but if you follow them if you believed
in what they believed back then you
would be a trump supporter today right
well I can't remember who made this
point but it was one of our guests and
they said do you think anyone who was in
a coma for 10 years and then woke up
today would go oh my gosh things have
gotten so far to the right like do you
think they'd read the newspaper and see
current events and go oh my goodness
this country's so conservative now I I
have uh
I'll try and keep as much information
you know private as possible but there
are certain individuals of moderate um
prominence who were let's just say uh
indisposed for a few years during the
Trump Administration when they came out
they were they were politically homeless
and confused because the left was not
the left anymore so uh I I used to hang
out with a ton of people in the hacker
community uh back preoccupy Wall Street
can they help my out my Google search if
they're listening to this I mean yes
they can guys shoot me a DM please these
are these are like reputation management
firms these days had all this stuff so
my hacker friends were pro-free speech
Pro edgy comedy they were very very into
Super offensive internet posts trolling
um goatsy stuff shock content lemon
party all those really awful things
don't let your kids go look up don't do
it yeah
something happened
they didn't tell the kids about it and
then tell them don't look so there there
are certain people who like they'll pay
the price oh I don't even know what that
certain hackers who end up going to
prison yeah with a limited access to
news and and the the internet culture
yeah they come out
and then all of a sudden they're like
all right where's the left and they're
like we don't like free speech anymore
and they're like what yeah and they're
like all the things you used to say and
do that we were friends with you for if
you do now we will punish you I mean
Louis J Gomez the Legion of skanks guys
were called proud boys Louis jomas who
is Puerto Rican they're some of the
funniest comedians in the world and I
did shows with them a couple weeks ago
and Their audience is if you just follow
Twitter you would assume it's an
audience of Nazis and Their audience is
diverse they are sweet
um they just like good comedy but now
yeah your friends get out of jail and
Ben Shapiro is the only one defending
Dave Chappelle where the right has
suddenly taken on Dave Chappelle and the
left is it's just again isolating and
alienating comedy fans now I will say on
the other side and I think this doesn't
have to do with left or right it's just
tribalism in general I remember
something that really disappointed me
was I went on a bunch of right-wing
shows and I stayed liberal you know I
went on Glenn Beck's it was great we
disagreed with some stuff but I got to
talk about Palestine and Glenn Beck show
that's dope and we mainly talked about
tribalism
and I did a bunch of other right-wing
shows
and again you're a grifter if I go on a
right-wing show and I start saying
things I don't believe in for money
right if I go on Glenn Beck's I'm like
yeah we build a wall and it's just stuff
I don't believe in but I was still
myself so I get like hundreds of new
followers and a bunch of people saying
the equivalent of I don't agree with you
but I like that you're trying to bring
people together blah blah then George
Floyd gets killed and I start posting
a bunch of don't kill black people
nothing crazy that old preachy Jamie
just don't kill black people and which
again even Trump and Pence ended up
saying that that was bad right
and I remember people even on my
Instagram which is usually less of a
cesspool than Twitter we're like oh
looks like feminist cuck Jamie's back
here we go with lip stuff and the fact
that I got canceled by some fake
feminists
implies that I have to be Pro George
Floyd being killed like that's why I
think tribalism is the problem
absolutely you know what I mean and
right now the left is doing it worse
than the right but it still happens on
both sides where don't don't pretend you
are above my politics and think I'm a
good guy and just while I can be used as
a prop of course where you can just
point to me and be like oh look at that
guy he's anti-woke he got screwed over
by whatever I'm like I don't want to be
anyone's prop I can still have these
thoughts that sometimes conservatives
will disagree with sometimes liberals
will disagree with that's why I think
it's the rule for the left the exception
for the right in terms of uh that
animosity the left is very tribal if you
deviate on one thing boom you're right
wing that's crazy the right you'll
certainly have people you know people
posted me and stuff and all the time as
well
um but for the most part you're they're
not gonna they might yell at you but
that's about it they're not gonna call
your boss yeah do you think a lot of
it's just Twitter in general because
when I meet liberal people at the gym or
on a date or conservative people I think
actually more people than we think feel
the exact same way we're talking you
just get the lunatics on both sides on
Twitter no they're just trying to get
into the body because they work for
Veritas
uh but we met organically no no no
there's the right way lunatics aren't on
on Twitter they're all banned
you're seeing the sanitized conservative
movement on Twitter and you're saying
The Fringe of the left on Twitter so
this was bad for Democrats and I I
warned about this like three four years
ago I put it this way you see two little
boys with a with an adult woman and
she's got two little boys with her one's
just drenched in dirt and chocolate ice
cream and he's all messy looking the
other kid is perfect and clean with a
smile on his face
and from the outset you say okay that
kid is a disaster he's messing that
other kid is is clean and responsible
but the reality is the mother just
doesn't let the clean kid have ice cream
so the kid who's allowed to have ice
cream makes a mess and the kid doesn't
allowed to heaven doesn't have the
opportunity to make a mess when Twitter
started suspending bad voices or voices
they thought were bad on the right they
were making it so that the most
prominent conservative people on Twitter
were Ben Shapiro you know a a practical
logical moderate conservative guy or I
should say a traditional conservative
and then the left is antifuse saying
burn it down and threatening death so a
regular person goes on and says oh
that's a little too much yeah this this
allows Twitter allowing the left to say
and do crazy things radicalizes people
it generates it charges up the engine
but people on the right are like I don't
want to get banned so I'm not going to
say that right it's actually making
people on the right try and dress up and
get clean and the left is running among
smashing windows and looking stupid
which is so funny because whenever my
argument for when people would equate
the extremes on both sides is I was like
oh what the left wants you to have like
too much health care or wants to end all
the war but yeah when you start
advocating violence it's like well no
that's that's who we're talking about
exactly and so this is an argument that
people on the far left are still making
so I saw this the other day when the
far-offs was referred to there were all
sorts of lefties going oh and it's far
left me they really want Universal
Health Care and I was like dude the
positions you're describing all apply to
Tim Poole but he's called far right it's
like well obviously we're talking about
the far left we're talking a lot about
the social issues yeah having policy
wise I think I would not compare
Universal Health Care to bombing Iraq
and Afghanistan but then again you have
Democrats who are also yeah droning
every Democrat voted to fund one of the
largest War packages in history with
Ukraine oh well it's like what six times
what anyone else in Europe has paid we
put in 54 billion dollars every Democrat
even the squad yeah so you know man that
that is it's funny when we have a debate
or argument with you know Matt on
abortion and I'm like this has never
been a really big issue for me because
for one I'm not a woman I'm not a a
legal moral or theological scholar I
mean it's I I you know I had a
conversation with Glenn Beck and
ultimately ultimately I ended with like
man I really just don't know I just feel
like there's a barrier for me and I
can't really I don't I don't have the
answer because they're good and like
that should be the answer if that but
War
this one's always been very clear-cut
for me and I know a decent amount about
what we do why we do it why we want to
enforce the Petro dollar I bring up all
the time the cutter turkey pipeline gas
problem all this stuff and I'm like it
is bad that we are doing these things if
you can go from being you're like I'm on
the left and and I'm like okay and
you're the anti-war party and then you
vote for Joe Biden right I'm going to
look at you and say huh yep and then
when Joe Biden's like come on you know
give me the biggest war package in
history you're like okay I'm like he's
folksy and progressives are pro-war yeah
progressives our pro-war liberals our
pro-war Democrats are pro-war and half
the Republicans are probably I mean I
discovered this I got in a lot of
trouble the one time and only time I
went on the Conan O'Brien show because I
talked all about drone strikes but I did
not talk all about drone strikes under
bush bush is when I started talking
about war but Obama was still using
drones so it was under Obama and the uh
it was me and Kobe Bryant were the only
other guests so not exactly like my
audience tuning in and if you watched
the clip the clip's probably still on
YouTube it goes well with the audience
but I was told it was the most
complaints they've gotten and that's why
my belief has always been just
principles of a party that's it it's if
you're anti-war be anti-war under Bush
the anti-war under Obama yes be anti-war
under Trump be anti-war under button
it's that simple but the fact that
there's such cognitive dissonance and
not only will suddenly they be pro-war
but then they're just getting defensive
and they're acting like you're a monster
for criticizing Biden or that Susan
Sarandon's the reason Roe v Wade's being
overturned it's absolute insane I'm
gonna I'm gonna cut them some slack and
say maybe it's not Joe Biden so maybe
voting for him it's not really the
problem uh I'm kidding by the way but
now I'm going to reference the story
from Fox Business Elon Musk slams Biden
the real president is whoever controls
the teleprompter musk also warned that
the U.S ignores obvious cause of
inflation it could end up like Venezuela
and he went on to say that someone could
bump the teleprompter and then Biden
would just read it like Ron Burgundy so
what I'm going to say is true we can't
blame those who are supporting Joe Biden
because Joe Biden isn't the president
whoever controls the teleprompter is but
well if you put Joe Biden there and he
is being directed by somebody else then
you voted for this you voted for the war
here we also talk about my favorite part
of that story was it was on Fox News uh
before the show and the Fox News anchor
had to essentially explain what the
movie Anchorman was he's like it is a
satirical line from a comedy movie where
laughter ensues well you know the
average uh I think what's the average
age of Fox News viewers my grandma 62.
what's the what's around burgundy it's a
comedy movie oh shout out to my grandma
who sent me a happy birthday text I did
not have her saved in my phone but this
but we got toxic family stuff because I
guess the whole show today is just like
literally Elon musk's Daily Business
he's just loving life right now yeah
that's great it's just uh
I gotta I I gotta look I gotta I Gotta
Throw back to this one because
while we're doing the show
he responded to Benny Johnson who
tweeted about the the guy saying
wokeness cost that money and he made the
like what is it like a depressed sad
face yeah yo I'm just gonna say this
they hurt his feelings the guy insulted
him for having Aspergers I think James
O'Keefe may have just saved Elon Musk
like 10 billion dollars I think
maybe 20 billion dollars
these videos coming out right now I will
I believe
I'm just I'm not a lawyer but it sounds
like it could give Elon Musk an actual
legal argument
as to uh to negotiating a lower price or
even having the contract contract be
broken no fee so if if either if if Elon
breaks the Twitter bio contract he's got
to pay a billion dollars if Twitter
breaks the contract they got to pay him
a billion dollars oh my god with these
videos coming out elon's clearly seen
them both
he can probably go to a court and say
they did not disclose to me these things
he wants kind of made Twitter fun again
yeah yeah yes it's like almost like
Trump yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
man Twitter was so fun under Trump was
like when people even I mean I was I was
not a trump supporter I was still pretty
Progressive but if you are really going
to look me in the eye and say when the
democratic debate was going on and Trump
just tweeted boring and all that that
wasn't the funniest thing in the world
you're a liar you are a liar well I mean
coffee yes it's got its own Wikipedia
entry I know it's a despite the negative
press confiti yes and I think they were
right despite the negative press
coverage but then mashed it with their
thumb and accidentally sent it or like
put in their pocket and it went off
something happened and we got the word
kofifi just delightful it was great who
was it was it Michael malice or am I
miss remembering who said something like
congratulations to all the former Trump
reply guys guys who can be Elon Musk
reply guys oh that's very funny that
sounds like a malice thing but I don't
know I don't know man I wonder if the
Elon Musk deal will actually end up
going through now yeah kind of crazy who
knows maybe he put project Veritas up to
this so he could get out of it he's like
there's a mess I don't want any part of
it
don't say it
so then in the skit James takes his mask
off and it's Elon the holes
no I think it's fascinating though um I
wonder if it I mean clearly this email
went out it looks like Veritas targeted
Twitter employees recently
you know it was the end of April
beginning of may all this was going down
so it seems like
Elon Musk might make save billions of
dollars thanks to the journalism of
project Veritas have you met O'Keefe
yeah yeah what's his deal Michael dude
yeah
he loves musicals yeah well turns out
I'll get along with him yeah
stop it yeah oh yeah he he and he was
like the main dude wasn't it yeah I
think he was I think he was just doing
an undercover operation yeah that's what
it was because any time that's the thing
anytime he does anything that he could
consider embarrassing he's like it was
an operation he's an operation he just
busts in after I got so excited and so
gay it was like he did Oklahoma that's
my favorite they're like busted he's
like actually a bunch of feminists were
mad about me they spread that rumor it's
not true I was never in Oklahoma I love
it no James is great yeah he loves to
sing and dance he loves Phil Collins
he's fantastic
all right time to do some research on
Old James O'Keefe when I get home
literally the skit would be literally
everything he does is a sting so he's at
like the supermarket and he's like
looking shifty-eyed as he like grabs a
box of Lucky Charms and like puts in his
why why Lucky Charms you know why you
know why you know why you all know why
it's unbelievable it's because you left
a box of Lucky Charms I did leave I'm
not gonna lie I did leave a box of Lucky
Charms like it was sent by a fan it was
sent by a fan it was sent by a fan to be
fair so uh I wasn't opposed to it Elon
Musk is criticizing Joe Biden and I
don't I don't know what else to say
other than he's uh I I one well I was
going to say something
um back to what you were asking me with
the cancellation and I also do wonder if
Elon with I'm gonna vote Republican is
either trolling because you don't know
who you're voting for there are horrible
Republicans or there's also part where
I remember when I did start to go on the
right-wing shows and you know five
people on Twitter were like oh here we
go here comes grifter he's gonna go all
Dave Rubin and become super conservative
or whatever agree and for me I
didn't because I mean I thought about it
I was like maybe I am conservative and
then I did watch a Ben Shapiro video and
I was like ah damn it I'm not
and uh but then but
but he did destroy you he did yeah
you're like I got destroyed it's not for
me
do I have one you were GOP curious Turn
the Lights real low you got another
covers you put on Ben Shapiro that's
literally what
I mean the first time I heard Jordan
Peterson I thought he was just going to
be screaming to kill trans people and I
was like okay okay my heart was really
saying I was having to watch the Rogan
and he was like make your bed and I was
like he was like I should make my bed
he's like I don't like large women
[Laughter]
I still remember having this moment and
maybe this sounds pathetic but whatever
when I walked into some of those offices
and having
and this was you know I had girlfriends
but I hadn't really jumped back into a
Social Circle I wasn't doing comedy uh I
was kind of doing Jiu Jitsu but going
into these offices and having everyone
know me hug me not shame me women like
host of the show put their hands on my
shoulder and be like I'm sorry what
happened to you sweetie I'm like sorry
what happened to me but I'm I'm the bad
person I'm the monster there is
something about when a pylon happens and
then the other side is just kind to you
and sometimes with an agenda but
sometimes just because I know a lot of
really nice conservatives I mean I've
had conservatives put me up when I was
homeless and we agree on nothing whereas
all of my Brooklyn woke friends it
didn't call are you telling me they
don't care about the homeless crazy or
are you telling me you need a place to
stay like you're trying to Blackmail me
here you're like they care about the
homeless because they have to move them
to gentrify the black parts of town to
get either Starbucks and Maca cafes or
whatever
Occupy Wall Street yeah I was physically
threatened numerous occasions I was
physically attacked three different
times you know during marches or at the
park and then I see a bunch of you know
Trump supporters you know people with
shields or maybe Flags I walk over and
they're like you want to grab a bite and
talk oh and it's just like look man I
don't have to agree with with the
conservatives but if they're willing to
sit down and have a burger and say well
I disagree let's have a nice day right
the other side is like we brought
crowbars right well I'll take it I'll
take a step further when I went on it's
called the real ass podcast Louis J
Gomez Who from legionist gangs his
podcast again he has been called a proud
boy there was a gay Comic-Con and the
gay Khan was like asked him about his
use of the the f word the other f word
and Lewis was like look I've said it
forever I've never set it towards a gay
person it's just the way I came up with
comedy but I tell young Comics you know
don't say it I wouldn't say it and most
importantly and I know Lewis very well
and this is I can vouch for this he's
like if I ever saw a gay person being
called that I would step in and I would
do something about it to the guy who's
being homophobic whereas any one of my
old Lefty friends if they saw a gay
person getting beat up they would run
away to the nearest Starbucks to maybe
tweet about it yeah they would write a
blog post about it for sure I was in
Portland proud boys were marching then
planned March antifa decided to counter
March and confront them the police had
to separate the two groups the proud
boys started marching
proud boys group was you know the people
of different races were there I don't
know I think it was mostly white people
probably and uh we got to this point
where all of a sudden Nancy started
yelling racial slurs at the black proud
boy really yeah and there's videos of
antifa yelling racial slurs at police
there's a black cop in there yelling
just racial Stars racial slurs at him so
they start yelling a racial slur at this
uh at this black proud boy and so he
breaks from the crowd and starts going
across the street yep and they're
they're yelling slurs like they're I
think they're yelling the n-word I think
they're yelling uh Uncle you know I
don't want to say it I don't entertain
it but they were yelling like the n-word
and other uh other words the c word
whatever
he goes across the street another proud
boy runs up to him and grabs him and
says don't take the bait dude don't
listen to them and then he grabs him and
says don't let him don't let him make
you hate man you're my brother we're
here together man we love you we care
about you and then they put their hands
together and it's like let's get to it
let's let's stay focused and they
brought him back in
there's a video there's an I uh an ice
protest
an antifa's outside and they're just
screaming the n-word at these black cops
yikes yo man battle
yeah Occupy Wall Street segregated
People based on race they you're in the
in the caucus voting system where they
would be like okay the everyone everyone
got a working group or a caucus your
working group was the work you did the
caucus was your race or gender or you
know Identity or whatever they had the
black caucus the Asian caucus Latino
caucus so you literally were voting on
resources based on your racial group
well and I remember even
with Ferguson and some of the black
lives matter protests there were also
black people stopping other a lot of
times white uh BLM Marchers from
vandalizing or from and it should show
you that
if you are on the right and thank
everyone who has March for black lives
matter is evil no there are really good
people who would do the exact same thing
if you think that there are proud boys
who are all violent no there are people
who will do the right thing and again if
those voices were the ones that would be
highlighted more instead of the fringes
we would actually probably agree on more
than we think we would let's uh we'll
we'll do a ridiculous segue and we'll
talk about it Dr Peterson I have been so
excited about this yeah so um I I had to
respond to Jordan Peterson uh the New
York Post reports Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit cover model critic Jordan
Peterson quits Twitter after backlash
bye for now I told Lydia his away
message should have just said no fatties
all right for sure so so there's a New
York Post posted this uh morbidly obese
woman on the cover of Sports Illustrated
and Dr Jordan Peterson said sorry not
beautiful and no amount of authoritarian
tolerance is going to change that
I I thought it was really funny I
thought it was tweet and I I think him
decided you know Jordan I think he's
great I'm a big fan I think him deciding
to get away from Twitter for a little
bit is probably a good idea for sure
Sheamus put it while you said oh just
about picking your battles choose your
battles man there's something in that I
kind of feel like when you when you when
you're swimming in the swamp for too
long actually is a better way to put it
be careful uh when fighting monsters
unless you become one for when you gaze
into the abyss the abyss case is back
Peterson would know that and so when I
saw this I kind of felt like are you
calling fat people monsters
no I kind of feel like
here here's here's the issue let me show
you these photographs
here here's Cosmo we've mentioned before
this is healthy it's a morbidly obese
woman here's another morbidly obese
woman says this is healthy I I think
these are awful I think these are
dangerous I think they're wrong I think
you should not encourage people to be
unhealthy uh obesity can cause cancer
there's a big uh Row in the UK because
there was an ad that was put up that
said the number I think it was like the
number one cause or like number two
cause of cancer or something and it was
obesity you need to guess the letter and
people were like this is fat shaming
so they also had the beach body ad of
like beautiful women taking down our
place of fat women I'm like that I can
understand when they're trying to
encourage there's a cover of Sports
illustrate they put a fat chick on it my
response was yo Dr Peterson some guys
like fat chicks like let them have their
day that was my favorite take dude but
also it's like the fact that the
argument went from don't sexually
objectify women to like make sure you're
more inclusive with your sexual
objectification exactly so strange but
that's literally where the left went
like no the larger women should be
objectified as well my favorite party
my favorite part of the day was after
you tweeted that imagining all my old
liberal friends being like Oh no do I be
mad at Tim Poole or Jordan Peterson
pick a side I just heads exploding
everywhere you know you know what's
funny it's how it works on Twitter is if
um
they they don't see the things I tweet
unless someone screen grabs it and the
only reason they'll screen grab it is if
they can mock it sure so when there are
tweets where I'm just like yeah like let
you know some people like fat chicks
like so funny let them have their day
you know what I mean I was just like I'm
not look saying encouraging it saying
it's healthy partly they're partly
encouraging it they're they're they're
they're putting on the cover magazines
but I'm also just like
I'm I'm not I'm not too concerned about
them showing a morbidly obese woman on
the cover of Sports Illustrated but I do
have questions and so the one thing I
would say is if Jordan Peterson
criticized it
appropriately I would I would be total
agreement and we were talking about it
what he said was authoritarian tolerance
not beautiful it was yeah it was like it
was like taking a sledgehammer to uh you
know like a wood nailer and then it was
so easy because then everyone just
started posting sad pictures of Jordan
Peterson and I was saying I mean he
could have just maybe texted a slightly
cuter member of the like intellectual
dark web just shot Sam Harris and be
like hey can you post this Sam it's got
dreamy eyes yeah I don't know I mean I
agree with you on the health thing I
when I taught Jiu Jitsu
um I've I've had a lot of people come to
me because they were overweight and they
were really sad about it and they were
embarrassed about it and I I don't I
haven't talked about this publicly
recently I wrote about it like a decade
ago but I've struggled with binge eating
I mean you would call it an eating
disorder if it was a woman you would say
I have an eating disorder
um food issues are hard man and the
times I've been overweight I've hated
myself and I still have body a
dysmorphia even though I train every day
and
but what you're saying about health is
so important number one if you just
quote unquote if you actually fat shame
people not with the left say is fat
shaming if you actually fat shame people
that's not going to help them right if I
see someone down the street I'm like Hey
fatty or whatever they're not going to
be like oh I better get to a Jujitsu
class they're gonna hate themselves more
and by the way same with what but
Sheamus would laugh and then high five
you and that would feel really why are
you why are you making this about me
you'd be like yeah what are you talking
about what if I ever indicated that that
would be my response to someone heckling
a stranger
the the craziest fat shaming story I
have when I have the old Progressive
podcast and I told this on a Rogan I
think but it still horrifies me is
there's a dude who wrote in and he said
his doctor said yeah same deal morbidly
obese essentially said he's gonna die
and he had kids
and was like I don't know what to do so
I wrote him an email I sent him a bunch
of healthy recipes I found him a Jujitsu
place I actually emailed uh Tim Spriggs
who ran the Jutsu score was like oh I
remember that guy
six months later eight months later
whatever it is he writes into the show
and he goes hey dude my doctor just said
he's never seen such a quick turnaround
before my kids are so proud of me and
I'm entering my first Wipeout Jiu Jitsu
okay cool now Lydia you're reacting like
a normal human being right right we got
six to ten emails the next day saying by
reading that email we were fat shaming
them and that's when I go and I was
still in my most Progressive most woke I
was like you would rather this dude die
and orphan his kids then temporarily
feel bad about yourself and maybe let
that inspire you to I'm not saying if
you don't do Jiu Jitsu you're a fatty
right I'm not saying it's a totalitarian
whatever authoritarian yeah
not beautiful yeah but hold on but can I
ask you something would it be helpful if
like you had a personal trainer who's
like you are going to be an
authoritarian
like you need to lose the weight make
this app make the Jordan Peterson weight
loss app yes we have that's another
sketch that's another I said clean your
room not your plate
just a bunch of lobsters going shame
shame shame shame I love it
before we move on this was my red pill
when I was 11 years old I looked at the
healthy at every size move and I was
like these ladies are not healthy and I
want to say there are two things here
one is subjective that is beauty you and
everyone else is welcome to think that
this lady is beautiful she is she's very
pretty 100 she's solid chunky Queen she
is a chunky Queen she is thick with
three C's and I there's no problem with
that I appreciate it however the other
is the objective and this is what I was
seeing when I was 11 I was like dude
these ladies are not healthy this is not
good this lady is not athletic I'm not
sure why she's on the cover of Sports
Illustrated I don't think she plays the
sport other than I don't know
[Laughter]
the eye contact you two made before that
life came out was beautiful so like I
know they couldn't do it though but
anyway it's like she's not healthy and I
know this isn't going to be good for her
down the line now Tess holiday really
troubles me because she's literally like
for Tim is just cracking I'm just
imagining Sports Illustrated doing like
the 12th annual covering access
I see it no don't predict the future
stop this stuff is not okay test
holidays like 400 pounds she's like I'm
so proud of myself I'm so healthy I'm
like b word no you're not you absolutely
aren't like I don't want anyone to hate
themselves right like I don't it's sad
it's sad to think of someone hating
themselves because they're fat and there
are a lot of people I'm sure I've been
listening to this show who's spiral
about that but it's and but it's
it's worse to hate yourself so much that
you end up in denial and you're it's the
same as when you tell your friends hey
I'm gonna quit drinking because you have
a drinking problem and your other
friends are drinking problems are like
well is your problem that you're a
little [ __ ] and they're trying to get
you to keep drinking it's like bro if
I'm an alcoholic and you are pushing me
to do it so you can feel better about
you know drinking on the weekends
because you don't want to see your wife
and little Spike kids then it's like
that's on you like that's messed up I'm
I'm Legit thinking that the future of
Sports Illustrated is going to be a
whole bunch of really nice stuff yeah
yeah because like angrily tweeting oh my
God
have you ever seen what's that what's
that uh morbidly obese women's clothing
store oh Lord
like they have mannequins that are
morbidly obese oh interesting and do
they just tie five other mannequins
together pretty much I don't know
I don't know if we can jump on YouTube
anyway no but I but I'm like mannequin
shaming there's a conspiracy theory
you know the dove real Beauty campaign
yeah uh do you know who owns Dove what's
the parent company of Dove no it's a
Unilever yeah oh no Unity Unilever owns
another another brand
Ben Jerry's oh boy
there was a conspiracy theory that they
were you know at a higher level we're
looking at like we want women to eat
more ice I was wondering why the woman
in the shower using Dove was eating
cherries yeah
so I'm pretty sure there's like a meme
about it but I mean it makes sense if
you were in a business and you're like
we want to sell soap to women and we
also want to sell ice cream but all
these super thin models are making
people not want to buy ice cream put the
fat women in the soap commercial and the
women will be like that's like me and
they'll eat ice cream and then Sports
illustrator we'll have ice cream eating
contests in their magazine what I mean
is if if the average woman is obese then
Sports Illustrated is going to start
putting more and more obese women on the
cover so with the body positivity thing
I want to sort of piggyback on something
Lydia said I actually I don't agree with
the idea that beauty is subjective I do
believe it's objective there are some
elements of our like experience of it
which is subjective I know well
but my problem is that you know what the
body positivity could have been affected
movement could have been effective at is
saying something like look
not everyone is physically beautiful in
the same way but just because someone
isn't beautiful doesn't give you the
right to treat them poorly because a
person's value is not limited to their
physical appearance and someone
shouldn't be treated poorly because they
don't look good and so instead they
decided to say actually everyone looks
good when what did that do that
solidified this idea that actually
appearance is what gives you your value
because we if we tell you you don't look
good then we are telling you your words
because that's what we believe so we
just have to instead of challenging our
understanding of what beauty means we
have to say no no everyone's beautiful
that way we can say everyone means
something instead of acknowledging that
beauty is not only a person's value a
quick fact check quick fact check we
have here the dove real Beauty Campaign
which was average to obese women and I
think they even had some some amputees
yeah Ben Jerry's parent Unilever
Dove owner Unilever conspiracy confirmed
oh boy it's happening what I was going
to say I love what you just said and
also the times even when I've been
struggling whether it's with depression
suicidal ideation uh uh binge eating
whatever it is the times where someone
actually made me feel good about myself
is when I would lock in and want to
double down yes the times where I would
just go you know what I'm a fat piece of
garbage well then what does a fat piece
of garbage do he certainly doesn't train
the next day yeah he feels bad he's got
to fill the sad hole in his heart so he
starts eating more food or you just go
well this is what everyone thinks I am
anyway right so Sports Illustrated you
actually have this opportunity to do
something like what you said but then
also write an article about hey you
don't think you're an athlete have you
tried these kind of sports have you
tried skateboarding have you tried Jiu
Jitsu have you tried something I failed
gym class literally failed gym class in
high school I'll tell you how you get
stoned every day and pretend you don't
have your shorts
and then I found Jujitsu at 17 and I was
like I always wanted to learn how to
fight because I grew up watching cheesy
martial arts movies and I fell in love
with Jiu Jitsu and accidentally became
an athlete because I found something I
loved you can help people you said you
felt so much better since did you like
give up sugar cut out cut out bread and
sugar yeah and like I want to ask you
advice about that after the show but
it's because I'm feeling good about
myself a heaping spoonful of almond
flour a heaping spoonful of Walnut flour
one egg yeah mix it up microwave for one
minute boom you got a keto biscuit then
I cut it I put cheese egg and bacon on
it and that's breakfast oh my God that
sounds really good yeah yeah all right
you know I think I think the issue is
when you're younger you need a bit more
food especially if you're athletic yeah
for me one of the issues was I used to
eat like 8 000 calories per day because
I would skate for eight hours a day yeah
and so it was just a machine when I got
older and started skating less and doing
you know news and stuff more I still had
the habits of eating big meals and then
you know I gained weight from it right
right right so now I'm like I still
skate a lot but it's remarkable that in
the past yo bro I I it's remarkable how
little I eat relative to what I was
eating last year yeah and it's crazy and
you probably feel great that's the thing
when I'm eating unhealthy
sure I could say you know I love my beer
gut I love my whatever but I don't feel
well and I get depressed and I sleep
later which means I don't go to the gym
and the times where I'm training and the
times where I'm eating healthy I feel
good and you want people to feel good
and again it's you don't have to say not
beautiful but man you can also encourage
people to be healthy because you want
them to feel good you don't want them to
be depressed the times I'm eating like
crap the times I'm overweight it
absolutely ties into my depression it's
horrible yes yeah well and no one really
openly says this right they'll just
apply this principle to different
categories all the time and hope you
don't notice but there's this weird
pervasive idea that like everyone is
equal in every single way so no one's
smarter than anyone else no one's more
beautiful than anyone else no one's
stronger than anyone else and it's just
not true it's just not true now again
what we should be promoting and this is
certainly what I believe is that you
know he humans are made in the image and
likeness of God every single person had
this unfathomable value but instead
because we have limited people's value
to what they bring to us instead of what
they are solely without seeing them as
full persons in order to compensate for
that we have to say Okay well yeah
people really are just their physical
makeup and they don't have any intrinsic
value besides these specific things we
decide to assign value to but they're
all equal in those categories so it's
fine I'm not caught up in the news who's
this God fella wow
so for those in the chat that are
getting triggered by my eating 8 000
calories
I was being I was exactly you're
hyperbolic yeah I was saying like I'm
eating an exorbitant amount how are you
not dead eating eight pizzas but no if
uh but but I will tell you it's like uh
not every day but days before and
sometimes after it would be excess of 3
000 calories and like yo oh hydrating
twice a day okay I'm murdering so
breakfast with like uh um meat potatoes
eggs toast you're looking at like you
know 800 with a glass of orange juice or
a thousand then you then you've got
lunch which was a couple sandwiches and
look at another six seven hundred for
dinner you get Panda Express double
orange chicken with a big thing of rice
it's like three to five thousand
depending on what you're eating some
days we get like we get Panda Express
three times yeah I also what seriously
skating for eight hours a day drenched
in sweat like I'm not kidding man no a
lot of my pro athlete friends can eat
garbage like there's a Jitsu fighter who
is famous for trying to get a Panda
Express sponsorship and there's there's
another one who only eats in and out and
five guys and stuff and they look great
and ripped and shredded but they're I'm
sure the inside of their body is dying
which by the way it's you could put but
that dude on the cover of Sports
Illustrated and it'll look great there's
like the whole skinny fat thing but
again he will be dead at 40. yeah and
that's why it was a red pill for me I
was like they clearly don't care about
women because they it looks to me like
they actually want them to Die Young you
can't tell me that you want these women
to see their grandchildren looks like
you don't even want them to live past
40. I gotta say I think it was Bill
Maher who said this but you don't see
fat 90 year olds and it's it's not to be
me but it's it's true it's very sad it's
very sad but it's true you don't it's
like well if you care about people and
you want to help them live longer lives
you should try to encourage them and
like you pointed out in a healthy way
you're don't be a jerk about it but you
should still try to encourage them to
get healthy yeah yeah no one of my
friends just hit me up today about
starting Jujitsu and he's a big dude and
I wasn't just like oh thank God fatty
what is your wife not doing you anymore
I just literally without saying it you
know I left him a voice memo on
Instagram and was like hey you're coming
in with me I'll take you into class I'll
make sure you don't have to pay let me
make you feel comfortable blah blah blah
and I just told him I told him I wasn't
athletic and Jiu Jitsu is what made all
the stuff I said to you guys and it's
like I'm so hyped to help this dude and
you know a lot of people who are
overweight they just kind of silently
suffer and they hate themselves and they
feel and again I I've been there on a
million different levels
um
and I don't think this stuff is helping
them again I think the Sports
Illustrated thing is harmless but I
think all that stuff that said like
healthy is just like reliable yeah right
I think there's there's some harm in the
Sports Illustrated thing I just think
you know Dr Peterson went a little too
far like yeah I don't understand that
hold back a little bit you know like I
would I would put LOL and be like no
thank you or something yeah LOL no thank
you even that though would be like kind
of a that would be kind of a wild tweet
to see from Jordan Peterson
that would have been incredible
incredible Jordan he tweeted that he's
like had his staff change his password
he's getting away from Temptation
getting off Twitter because it's toxic
and the barrage of insults and I'm just
I just I'm confused by that
um
I got I get it for some people having
just millions of people tweeting hateful
things at you you know some people can't
handle that that's very simple Tim loves
it he's like are you kidding like what
I'm trending right now I've been
trending for like four days straight and
you know what I do I posted the Elmo
fire Emoji like say my name this is this
is what I need to learn from you I
almost asked you this when we were
hanging out earlier but I wanted to save
it for the show yeah because so I had
John Cleese on my podcast and like a
month or two ago and if you guys from
Monty Python blah blah and he's been
canceled a bunch this year and he told
me he doesn't know why and he's like I
don't look someone says hey you're
trending on Twitter and he goes all
right I don't care and then he goes and
he lives with his you know Monty Python
money and lives a happy life right what
I think one of my problems was that I
couldn't take it mentally like I was
suicidal I did disappear and stuff like
that and so now that I'm sort of just
diving into comedy and in comedy you
don't really care as much and you can
make things
jokes and that's all that matters
because my problem too was I was I was
just Niche famous enough to get canceled
but like not famous enough to have a
savings account or like a pool and so
you know I see like John Cleese and I go
well yeah you don't have to look at
Twitter but I gotta get booked at the
Chuckle Hut in Kansas City and have a
you know creepy Anonymous Twitter
account like dming their GM and so
but I also think that part of the reason
you blew up was that not caring and by
you not caring you were establishing
your loyal fans which I didn't do I just
like pieced out because I thought I was
so gonna die I come from the internet
era of you like trolling to like you go
on forums and you post things to get
attention right so when I saw the people
that all called me Cox I'll see like you
know you know vosh Trends a whole lot as
well really yeah yeah yeah and so like
I'll see you know he'll be twinning like
like a thousand four hundred and I'm
like those are rookie numbers you gotta
get those numbers up first but he had a
funny tweet too he said I forgot what he
said but he said I have I have I'm gonna
paraphrase but something like I have
stared to the eyes of the of the Beast
and nothing scares me more than this
this monster and it was a screen grab of
vosh trending that was a good one yeah
you know look criticize the guy in all
that stuff I thought that was a funny
twist very funny but uh when I yeah when
I see like Tim pool trending and I'm
like why is it so low like come on man
it's it's like it was like 3 900. so
what about when you if you hate me get
those numbers up baby well what about
when you were like coming up dealing
with the hate or when you didn't have as
strong a network I mean the truth is I
literally just never cared Houston so so
like when we started there's so much
guys no but but look when we started
doing this show we're getting like uh I
don't know shy of a thousand concurrents
or something yeah I don't care I wanted
I wanted to do the show because I was
bored right I want to do it right and
then people say nasty things about you
and they criticize you and you're just
like oh
I guess man
I grew up on the internet people say
nasty things all the time you also
always had because I realized one of the
reasons that I'm so confident right now
is because of this I have a solid
Community for the first time in my life
in Texas in Jiu Jitsu in comedy where I
have my favorite Comics are my friends
even just doing this with you guys I'm
like okay cool I have like new friends
now
um my Jiu Jitsu Community if people say
untrue things about me in Jiu Jitsu
unlike my old friends who were like well
I can't tweet about Jamie I don't want
to lose my free internship at the nation
it's like these Jujitsu guys they don't
care at all they're like yo we will go
to war for you do you need us to go to
war for you do you need my lawyer I will
give you my lawyer like literally doing
things like that that's what I was gonna
say is I wonder if even when you didn't
have huge fans you had your crew and
whereas I didn't have anybody no I've no
crew I mean like I got I shot back by
myself and for the most part you know
half the people got beat with me half
don't and I'm just like I'm doing my
thing and you just didn't care yeah I
don't care I never cared I mean uh I I
care about like
I care about Freedom personal
responsibility I care about truth I care
about that okay so what about when
people say stuff that isn't true because
that'll happen to me sometimes where
I'll post something and someone just
writes you were accused of sexual
assault and I want to just go no I
wasn't because I wasn't but I also don't
want to address it and that look at me I
agree I mean it's it's annoying but then
there's also like
as someone with 100 followers will say
it's not true and I'm like okay I could
respond to them and try and convince one
person or I can do my show and convince
a million right so I'm just gonna keep
doing my just getting bigger getting
bigger we gotta go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only segment probably talking about the
apocalypse and 10 gas so uh again
timcast.com that'll be up around 11.
let's read
all right let's see woot do for use at
fact check the Twitter engineer said he
worked four hours last quarter not per
week holy moly oh wow so that's even
worse that's horrible all right we were
doing that due to solid right we were
trying to cover for him yeah
it's four hours a week it's a lot
let's see shame train Tim and crew how
long do you predict until the U.S
completely fractures and things gets
truly violent to keep being you
some people were chatting that vosh was
saying the leftists need to get armed or
something but I don't know if that's
true because I didn't see it I just saw
it in the chat also none of us know how
to shoot guns so it's fine we're all
just gonna accidentally like Friendly
Fire each other oh my God you uh I I
actually started trading with Tim
Kennedy and those and the Sheepdog guys
in Austin that's what switch my gun
views but who was we in that one Oh Me
Oh him oh I don't know I don't know no
you're like we don't know how to shoot
guns oh I just man like that oh I guess
I still call myself liberal I guess I
got really great
um basic pointers and we've been to the
range quite a bit and we have property
where we can shoot yeah tons of guns now
far from an expert or any or anybody
deeply involved in any kind of gun
culture but uh I've been to the range
and uh pretty good yeah with uh uh I
will say I find long guns to be
relatively easy with with simple
training practice I shot a pistol but I
have guns I'm not that good yeah it's uh
you have to train though that was the
first reason I wanted to train and I hit
up Tim is one I want it to be hey I was
a really anti-gun guy and I think it
would be cool to learn from you and also
talk to those guys about what they think
reasonable gun control is or what you
should do for mass shootings or whatever
and I had some of the most open-minded
conversations I've ever had which have
definitely switched my uh views on guns
but I remember Tim came to me after the
seminar and he was like Hey I want to
get more women people of color
LGBT people here to train to learn how
to defend themselves I don't want to
just to be like white militia Tim
Kennedy Fanboys and I was literally like
you are doing more for people than any
of my old liberal friends I posted a
picture of a gun on a trans flag
and then I said uh
uh you can't tell me that with this tree
yeah it's a trans gun rights are human
rights I love it and I said I think
black Trans women should have 50 bmgs
mounted on their rooftops if they so
desire and they should be able to carry
AR-15s to protect themselves from white
supremacists to bigots who would do them
harm and the uh trans people filed
takedowns against me and got it removed
from Twitter that's insane yeah oh I
should say the left that I don't know
exactly who did it that's right but it
wasn't my photo that's why so they filed
a claim against me and then Twitter
deleted it and I was like they don't
want me agreeing with them okay they
were like they kept saying it was a joke
and then I was like what what's a joke
about me so there was someone who was
like just because it's hilariously
worded does not mean I thought it was
legitimately I still think it's very
funny you know so I I uh somebody
somebody commented like you talk big
game about guns but the moment black
people get guns where are you then and
then I said I think the Black Panther
should be armed to the effing teeth yeah
but also they just like they just make
things up they create imaginary
scenarios in their their head they're
like what would you say then the thing
that's consistent with my principles
because I don't just hate whatever group
you've assumed I've hated to smear me
right yeah Killer Mike from run the
jewels was the first person that made me
think about my my stance on guns yeah
he's great all right let's read some
more we got boof good name he says can't
wait for the Republicans to regain
control so they can continue to do
absolutely nothing yeah well go and vote
in your primaries and make sure the
people who are winning are people who
will do things I saw Rand Paul won his
primary yes of course he did yeah of
course of course
Mary Diaz says I promised I wouldn't
sign up for another subscription but
Sheamus is amazing so I've got to also
Tim do you need someone for HR I'm
working on my certifications but I am
young and a hard worker love the show
um we may be getting to that point
because we're relatively small but we're
growing yeah maybe
um I don't know HR would not let you say
we're small and growing by the way yeah
yeah we're we're actually we're a shower
not a girl
good stuff great work Everyone by the
way thank you so much for the compliment
Mary it's very kind that was interesting
Ian Kenny said Tim all your button UPS
dirty did you see John Rich's retweet
that Elon replied to he did I didn't see
that which one was that
I don't know
um no I just I just wore a a teal shirt
today Sam we were both getting lit up
about our shirts in the chat oh really
people like oh he's the [ __ ] the Sheamus
Blends in I got my camouflage today man
I was hoping I could hide so I was I was
skating and I fell and I whacked my arm
really bad and so now I just like I just
sat down I was like
I'm exhausted and then you know normally
I'll go and I'll get ready for the show
this time I'm just like greasy sweaty
and stinky
uh so whatever you're like the guest is
a canceled comedian that's right fine
yeah like offend this yeah yeah it's not
James O'Keefe
I'd be wearing a suit no I honestly it
might be James O'Keefe where's the
camera oh yeah sounds like James that's
definitely something James was saying is
that I'm not James O'Keefe all right
let's grab some more super jets
people mentioning the new uh Veritas uh
posts
Paul Jones says MB was super cringe guy
is banality of evil incarnate couldn't
hold a consistent position
intellectually bankrupt it was indeed
like speaking to a brick wall you and
Sheamus had did good had
uh I thought you know I thought Matt was
a was a cool guy he was a nice guy we
had we had a quote we hung out before
and after the show when it got into
politics I felt confused because I
didn't understand what what his
principles were I understood his
platitudes like when he said
conservatives think trans people don't
exist but I when I asked them what does
that mean like what idea are you trying
to convey he couldn't say anything it's
just like it just didn't mean anything I
still have no idea what they mean when
they say conservatives think trans
people don't exist like Ben Shapiro
walks into Blair white and then he goes
where did she go we're friends there
it's gone yeah I just don't understand
what they're trying to say yeah and they
don't clarify either
I would like to say I think trans people
exist I think they do too yeah yeah I
I've been misled yeah what is what is
are they trying to say something like
you don't really yeah I don't know
right exactly it's not true but when I
say what idea are you trying to convey
and they say uh I'm like well if you
can't explain it yeah
yeah all right Bobcat says if she's a
Ted at you're a two she's James okay
that is what everybody in Twitter used
to walk around with that's what the
tweeb memo should be yeah it should have
said guys you're not that attractive
yeah
they're like we specifically hire people
who don't look good enough to believe
they could be getting a date with
someone that attractive you're not hot
stop spilling company in town but I
really just love that they emailed the
guy and he's showing it off that was
that was incredible yeah that was a
cartoon
he's like the Bear Child Support is like
what's this project Veritas
if then the Veritas guy uh the guy who's
filming he says aha I am Veritas but
then the guy he's filming goes I was
James O'Keefe the whole time they're
both parents wait a second why did we do
this I don't know man I want a drink
yeah everyone is James but then Veritas
puts together like a hit piece on
Veritas they're like project Veritas
agent doing you know it would be another
funny skit is a person working at
Twitter who is paranoid and thinks
everyone is James O'Keefe and so he like
he grabs he grabs an old woman he's like
pulling on her hair like take the weight
I know that's you O'Keefe yeah yeah
so let's ad-lib all of these dude we
should do a bunch of these for sure or
one 20 minute long one
all right
Sam Weider says I sent this chat
yesterday but gladly sent it again since
yesterday's show was amazing when I was
watching your segment about Disney I
thought about the South Park episode
about the pedo group nambola
hahaha
make 1984 fiction again says since you
didn't get this yesterday I'll try again
there's no such thing as a viability
argument there is no such thing as a
baby as a baby viable in or out of the
womb until three years old that's
generous
but I I understand that point but the
idea being conveyed is there's a point
at which the baby doesn't need to rely
on the blood of the mother
like it can it can be sustained through
technology uh that's why I asked that
question
I can't remember who I asked but like if
a baby from day one can moment of
conception could be taken out in place
in an artificial womb should that be
required for any abortion
like if you don't have to kill it why
kill it you know what I mean
I think I think the issue is oh yeah I
think the issue is that a lot of
abortions are due to financial issues
and so it's like the intentional killing
of the baby because they they're like
well I can't afford it so when I brought
that up to Matt the other day I said
well what about a man who also can't
afford it can he choose his ever
responsibility he said no then I'm like
okay well I don't know how you have the
argument that a woman who can't afford
the baby can aboard it but the man who
can't afford the baby has no choice and
has to become and go to jail for being a
deadbeat
you got to be consistent man I'm trying
to figure out what what what these you
know what your positions are for these
for these guys
many strange quarks says Sheamus please
make a tune of James O'Keefe in drag on
a sting that would be hilarious all of
you at the Castle Rock chicken City
forever well I'm sure you you have been
uh pleasantly surprised by all the
O'Keefe skits we've been coming up with
here so we um
it has to be a musical parody it has to
be to like a Hamilton or Oklahoma for
James O'Keefe like give it a me yeah it
has to be oh that's awesome I like the
wedding one
the wedding one I just want someone to
go through their whole life and at the
very end of their life their spouse is
doing a hit no the child they had with
their spouse was doing an O'Keefe hit
piece the whole thing was set up
all right
you're like dude James O'Keefe puts a
liberal like in The Truman Show he like
raises a liberal from birth in The
Truman Show
it is the live streams and he's like
this is who they are This Is How They
think this proves it this proves how
Liberals are he's proving the point that
a liberal from birth would retain so
he's like we've kidnapped the child of a
liberal family now we're raising it in
isolated space to see what behaviors it
has to prove whether or not Liberals are
inherently you know liberal
all right Iggy the incubus says hey yo
Tim as many times as your streams have
gone down all of a sudden are you sure
it's not it's not actual malice from the
overlords at YouTube at this point no I
think it it is I mean we we did a
segment where he who shall not be named
was named and then the stream goes down
halfway through yeah
there was a stream that went down but
chicken city which is streaming to the
same network was live so we had a
chicken city outside they're streaming
from the same network
how does that happen how does that
happen huh
oh okay we'll grab some more Morgan H
says James O'Keefe oh James oh cafifi oh
yeah James Oaks
very nice
Fire Sky says very nice shirt Tim also
please do that skit
yeah
I mean I would I would love to actually
have James come down to be in a system
that would be so good it'd be hilarious
messages
take the wig off and it's James or or it
could just be James in the suit in a
full suit but also wearing a ruler and
the guys are like what's up girl yeah
you want to hear about my Twitter
hijance
yeah you want to hear about some
corporate malfeasance girl I know it's
I've only just met you but let me give
you this Ledger of every illegal thing
I've done I wouldn't do this if we
didn't meet organically yeah that's
right
all right seriously JK says Sheamus the
undercover dude knew his audience
perfectly that being the Tweet he played
directly to him because he knew he could
while mocking him at the same time it
was actually brilliant improv in my
opinion
I don't think that guy knew it was
Veritas
so bizarre because it's like yeah it's
so hysterical
Tipsy yeah so maybe I mean Neo Reaper
says instead of punked you get O'Keeffe
Sheamus get on it oh my gosh it's like
actually you weren't on a day you
confessed to criminal activity and
they're like ah you got him dude
so many good ones write them down with
this with this guy like I I'm still
stuck on what is this project burritos
like that's something that's something
someone in a fake mustache says
I know well that was the gay one he
could have had a fake mustache yeah yeah
they all do even like the beautiful
women are wearing fake mustaches they're
like the glasses with the big nose yeah
like the glasses looks like a giant
camera protruding
Aldo says O'Keefe sends 100s the entire
bar was O'Keefe oh he sends hundreds the
entire bar was O'Keefe oh my God oh my
gosh
dude
dude he could literally put a cardboard
cutout on a remote control car that had
a camera attached to it and these people
would spill their secrets to it I'll
tell you yeah so so hold on so the guy
who gets stung by Veritas on his you
know he's dating a girl and then he
pulls the wig off it's it's O'Keefe and
he's like it's too late you've said
everything ah he becomes paranoid so
then he goes to work and then someone at
the office is talking to him and he's
like I I admitted everything and then
also he's like wait a minute and then he
pulls the wig off and it's James again
yeah starts freaking out so then he goes
to therapy and he's sitting on the bed
and the doctors and the thera's like
tell me what it's like at your job and
he's like well what's been happening is
wait wait a minute no no it can't be and
then he pulls the wig off of the
therapist as James O'Keefe no no but the
solution or the resolution is the you
know entire world is turned against him
but fortunately they're all James
O'Keefe so he's like he's like well this
guy didn't like me anyway yeah
all right we'll grab some more
a lot of people pointing out the other
Veritas video
Charles Fritz says date videos allow The
Whistleblower to feign outrage and keep
their jobs get Christian Westbrook
Westbrook from Ice Age Farmer on the
show please that sounds cool
Charles Bloomer says this is for shim
cartoon skit for you sir a commercial
for Justin Trudeau charcoal facial mask
hilarious that's a good one oh my
goodness and and then it ends with being
like uh and coming soon the Ralph
Northam
oh my gosh North on bed sheets
yeah yeah
yeah
um what are they called die cut bed
sheets
pims the great says sent this yesterday
before YouTube deleted everything just
close on nine and a half acres for my
Homestead Monday but wanted to ask your
opinion on BlackRock owning 75 of
ancestry.com scared that they now have
access to people's DNA
yes they do is ancestry DNA
DNA I'm pretty sure ancestry inside an
industry for a while and it's just like
but you said like you still have
ancestry yeah
23andMe was is the is the yeah you send
your blood or something yeah I never did
that I was like I just did oh my God
they send you uh they send you a small
knife in a package and you slice your
palm and then squeeze yeah they don't do
it and then a guy brother is with you
and does rituals with your blood you
actually just like swab your cheek or
something but uh I always thought it was
funny that movies they'll take when it's
like the ritual calls for blood and
they're like let me slice my entire Palm
open instead of like poking my arm break
your finger yeah it's like how much
blood did you need he's trying to show
that they're hardcore and then their
hand is like fine or they'll just wrap
it and it's like bro you're not gonna be
able to like it's Gonna Hurt they're
like we need blood let me cut my arm off
all right
PRC E5 says I'm picturing James O'Keefe
as Willem Dafoe and Boondock Saints and
Saints at the end yeah reference
yo James we've got so many funny skits
what when are you thinking as soon as
humanly possible yeah as soon as humanly
possible we could easily do this all we
need is a wig yeah that would be really
funny all right it's a beautiful lady
we'll figure out
I mean look if we did it with okay we
could also no I mean we could also
literally I could do a cartoon event we
could just like if he's interested send
his voice and that'd be good
but there's like so many I know well
we're gonna do 50 of them
no but I I would love to do a physical
that would also be hilarious just with
him yeah yeah it would be hilarious
we can also do the you know some of them
yeah so your idea is fine too shame yeah
for the people who didn't listen to this
episode if I was watching a sketch and
you know it's a James O'Keefe sketch and
then the reveal is it's actually James
O'Keefe like I would pop huge for that
it's a it's like a five foot three like
skinny blonde chick tell me more about
your job Wow have you done anything bad
yeah and he's like oh yeah yeah here's
what I did and then
wait a minute
you've ever done anything bad yeah
here's the documents but can you Xerox
that for me I do have a portable scanner
right here
I knew bringing this scanner on all
these dates would finally pay off
all right
Derek says your possible skit is a
remake of you got mail I don't know what
that one is
the
also which possible skit because we got
like 50 of these I know so good and the
James the Droid Jordan Peterson weight
loss program oh that's right that has to
be done as well I think you can play
Peterson I do I do little cartoons he
tells everyone to only eat meat right
yeah yeah the body the archetypal hero
stop eating off with all the food his
weight loss app is called the hero's
journey I like that I would definitely
that's actually a good name
maybe write it down maybe funny if like
in a week Jordan's got a new book called
the hero's journey and it's like a
weight loss plan I love it and then
you're like I came up with that and he's
like prove it
you're not beautiful come on Peterson
stop shaming me come on man all right
Xbox hog says almost died today by
turning off the main breaker of my
soaking wet circuit breaker box did not
get electrocuted but I was really dumb
don't do that yikes summer Andre says
Abby Johnson is a great person for
perspective she used to run a Planned
Parenthood until she had to assist in
one and watch the baby fight against the
tools Stu Peters has a great interview
with her wow I want to get her on
crazy
blades will bleed says every miscarriage
will be treated as a possible homicide
is the fear being expressed by saying
making miscarriage illegal not expressly
legal but effectively if they're all
treated as a crime that's not how it was
in any state where abortion was illegal
prior to Roe v Wade it's not as if women
had miscarriages and then the police
showed up to their house to investigate
it's ridiculous yeah I also suppose it
depends on the so you would be against
that if someone did you can't like
investigate people for miscarriage right
no yeah well you could what if a woman's
eight months pregnant and the baby you
know she hasn't so so if you have
something if there's like a dumpster or
baby like a you know a dead child found
in a dumpster or something like that
yeah you would have to investigate
because that's insane but yeah but I
actually maybe I don't know if can you
have a miscarriage at eight eight months
I think it's much less likely than
earlier I think it would be called
something different at that point
I think it's still a miscarriage at that
point I don't know yeah
so um
the the issue at play with the argument
is typically the left is arguing like if
the baby's dead you then you need to
abort that's right it's the removal of
Liberty well the CDC says the
termination of a pregnancy with uh with
with a not live birth yeah so uh if
that's the idea they're trying to convey
I'm trying to steal man their approach
my responses then put that in the law
then right then make it clarify that
that the life of the baby must be
preserved at all costs yeah also they
just May issue it up all right but the
issue is despite you know Matt the other
day arguing repeatedly that it's for the
health of the health of the mother he
kept he also said when pressed well the
woman can get an abortion electively
it's her choice also no there is no
single piece of proposed pro-life
legislation and there is no pro-life
advice kissy group or any group that has
ever said we need to make it illegal to
re remove a miscarried baby if necessary
you got to keep it fresh it's just it's
ridiculous no one says that it's an
insane yeah so miscarriage after 24
weeks is called they still
yeah yeah I thought it was I thought it
was something else yeah
it is Carriage good point so in which
case yeah miscarriage wouldn't be
investigated right no yeah yeah because
that's like miscarriage has
pre-viability I have been shocked by the
number of people who are like well then
our miscarriages abortions I'm like no
it's a horrible sad thing not least what
happens not legally so the the important
spontaneous abortion is sometimes a
medical term people use yeah but that's
what what I mean is
I want to make sure we're addressing
their idea right and not using words
that they used right well the removal of
a Mis of an unfortunately miscarried
baby is called a d and c dilation and
carotage which
is unfortunately if the pregnancy has
already been terminated
miscarriage or stillbirth then abortion
is the termination of the pregnancy that
doesn't result in a live birth according
to the CDC not to start more heated
abortion stuff I'm just going to
disappear you're about to yeah
more expensive whiskey
um what's the pro-life stance genuinely
this is not no I gotcha thing when on
the argument where it's abortions are
still going to happen but not safe and
legally so you know a kid who is raped
and his parents are going to disown them
or you know like some of these
um
I have friends who were I mean I've been
in relationships with women who were
raped and they were afraid to tell their
parents because that was just the
dynamic where they would have been
ashamed or whatever so people who have
to then sneak off to get less safe
abortion so the argument essentially
saying that yo they're still going to
happen but it's just not going to be as
safe if you don't have access is there
sort of like a well we can do this
solution from the pro-life stance on
that no that's a really good question so
basically my there's a few points so
there's the point about you know people
are going to break this law so what do
you have to say about that then there's
this question of whether they're going
to be unsafe procedures if abortion
isn't illegal I think for the first
question I would say anytime we
Implement any kind of legislation to try
to help people or save lives some people
are going to break the law I don't think
that's a good reason not to pass the law
so I know in Texas even it's difficult
to have perfect metrics on this but
we've seen something like a 66 percent
decline in the number of abortions that
have happened there
um and when it comes to the back alley
abortion narrative
this is a mostly mythical idea that's
been sold to the American public that
prior to Pro Roe v Wade because abortion
was illegal you just had thousands of
women dying in these risky procedures
Bernard Nathanson was an abortion Doctor
Who was I believe the founder of an
organization called nehrol and he
admitted after he defected from the
pro-choice movement that all of the
numbers they produced for the number of
women who died in back alley abortion
procedures were completely fabricated
the media printed them it wasn't true so
in 1933 there were about 2 700 recorded
deaths from abortions and miscarriages
together in the entire country by the
time he gets to 1945 that number is
under 900
um and then by 1972 there were 63 and 38
percent of them happened in states where
abortion was legal the reason is that as
penicillin has become more widely
available
fewer women die from abortions and
miscarriages yeah yeah antibiotics have
become more widely available so it's not
penicillins like the Ben and Jerry of
the abortion complex well penicillin is
mostly like not even in use I'm pretty
sure fair but antibiotics generally
speaking Yeah so it was it was an issue
of people not having access to
antibiotics and again before abortion
was illegal 38 of the deaths from
abortion were taking place and states
where abortion was legal how do you deal
with any other illegal medical procedure
yeah I mean they they happen it's not
like we you know we don't see people
going out and being like people are
illegally selling body parts yeah I
think even broken was talking about that
about how there might be more do they
call like medical tourism where people
kind of crossing state lines if it's
going to go state by state to find it
what was really interesting to me
learning the numbers about abortion was
this what a huge percentage of it is
completely just because ladies like I
don't feel like being pregnant in fact
Abby Johnson was just talking about a
lady who aborted her 16 week old fetus
because she wanted a summer body wow
unbelievable let's read some more we got
I hate it so much Brody ninja says Hey
Chicago boys I'll be in Chicago
Schaumburg in two weeks for a Winnie
City Pony con
I've been recommended Giordano's and Lou
Malnati's for pizza any other places
that it'd be cool to check out while
there hmm
um let's see we have a bunch of
Giordano's actually here in the freezer
it is delicious I love it uh I don't eat
the crust though just the cheese Lou
Malnati's is also extremely good and
they're both good in different ways
now if you want to know the secret
you got to go down to Archer Avenue on
the south side of Chicago and you got to
go to one of two places or both there's
Villa Rosa
on Archer near
um near Central I can't remember maybe
it's on like Latrobe or something and
then there's Danny's
Danny's Pizza which is like maybe that's
Latrobe they're both on Archer so if you
look by Midway Airport and those are the
pizza places that and all
of my friends and I we grew up eating
and that's like the real Chicago pizza
do you go to Giordano's Illuminati you
get the tourist pizza if you want to get
the real square cut semi-fit crust with
thick cheese on it you go down you go to
those places that's how I feel about the
Philly cheesesteak thing where they're
like Gino like the two main ones are not
good and it's just everything in the
surrounding area is very good
all right let's grab uh we'll try and
grab a couple more because we went a
little over
Christopher Macy says Tim you said
people can't grow their own food to feed
themselves in cities please check out my
page on Tick Tock at rebuilding life
Gardens one this is not true
uh there are Urban Gardens that I know
about places like Detroit they've
created Urban Gardens and there's also
balcony and rooftop gardens so I'm sure
um I could be wrong but I wonder if
you'd have the acreage to sustain the
population of the city I don't that's
just not possible you know the pop so I
think if you look at the amount of
available arable land in a City versus
how many people live there you have to
drop it down by 99 I mean you can grow
some food right but I don't think you
could it's impossible to sustain
yourself you know we've got I think now
with the babies maybe like 40 chickens
and I'm like it's great every three
years you you get to eat one when they
stop laying I suppose you can eat it
once it's fully grown by like if you're
if you're doing Broiler heads or
something
maybe you'll eat the roosters or if it
upsets you but uh or if it's just add a
line or yeah or if someone it loves
upsets you but if they're laying eggs we
don't want to eat them and then they lay
for like three years
so but if you have if you have the
proper cycle going you'll always have a
couple chickens but you gotta understand
guys
one chicken gets you two wings
technically you got the flats and the
drums so maybe four but when you go to a
when you go to a restaurant and you're
like I'm gonna get 12 wings in Buffalo
sauce 12.
how many chickens three to six chickens
depending on if you're getting flats and
drums well Tim I hope modern science is
working on that yeah we can have
chickens with 12 wings who says why not
man old Jamie would have gone on an
hour-long vegan tirade so you're welcome
Super Chat VOC says I am become James
O'Keefe destroyer of tweeps
tweets bro
Gundam Wing says I've heard a lot about
women's rights and talk about babies
when it comes to abortion what about the
father's rights it takes two to make a
baby but I haven't seen anyone talking
about the father's rights should women
get abortions against the father's
wishes well the pro-choice guy I guess
said men have no choice so I think he's
anti-choice
so I don't know
um I think you know there's got to be
responsibility involved
and there's a serious question but the
father's rights but it's not the father
carrying the baby which is it is the
legal question of um
the rights in question so when it came
to the Supreme Court decisions they're
like well there's the woman but then
there's the baby and they're both in the
same space the father's not in that
space so it's I don't know how that
would work
but I think we need cultural Solutions I
think our culture needs to decide you
know what we will and will not accept
there are certain things you can't do
there are certain things you can
yeah I mean it's the woman's body if if
because I I was trying to think about it
because I'm Really Gonna meditate on a
lot of the things you guys said because
it's stuff I legitimately never thought
about when you told the story about the
the baby who was coming out like I
gasped because I never heard those
stories before and so I was trying to
think about it but especially I mean if
you make it equal I mean it is the
woman's body it's the government it's a
woman's body and if you're in an abusive
relationship if you know there's so many
dicey situations where if it was equal
like it's not equal it is in one of our
bodies it's not it's not ever going to
be equal yeah it's impossible yeah
because women carry babies and men don't
yeah period but now there's a viral you
know maybe we should talk about there
are these viral posts going around of of
men breastfeeding
I yeah I think we should let's let's
talk about that because we're talking
about this right so here's what we'll do
head over to timcast.com become a member
we're going to address the questions of
equality on this issue but there's viral
posts going around I think Libs of tick
tock had it where men are taking hormone
pills to induce lactation so they can
share the burden with their wives yeah
I'm definitely gonna have more whiskey
yeah have some more and this is going to
be an interesting conversation
I didn't need to know I'm glad you're
gonna know that I didn't and I'm going
to show you pictures
all right all right smash the like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show if you really do like it again
timcast.com sign up if you want to
support our work you can follow the show
at timcast IRL we post on Instagram
every day clips from the show and it's
been growing like crazy so we really
appreciate it you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at timcast Jamie
you want to shout anything out yeah uh
Instagram at the Jamie killstein you're
probably better out there because I
preemptively have a lot of you blocked
I'm so sorry on Twitter from my old days
uh but my Twitter's at Jamie killstein
and the podcast is a F ups but spelled
out uh Guide to the universe or you can
go to Jamie hilsteinpodcast.com by the
way I can't believe you Hypocrites were
complaining about the formula shortage
and you don't want men to lactate
you so called yeah yeah exactly
Hypocrites Hypocrites
um so my name is Sheamus I have YouTube
channel called Freedom tunes please go
there check that out we are also going
to be launching the freedom Tunes
website on May 30th and if you go to
that website sign up for the mailing
list right now there's a little
receptacle there for you to put your
email when we launch we're going to be
uh archiving all the cartoons there and
also we are going to be uh having a
paywall up so for five bucks a month
you'll get one extra cartoon per week
and you'll get behind the scenes footage
like you know Tim and I improving the
videos we work on together and
commentaries those are even more fun
those are those are a lot of fun yeah
the uh the chicken one was one of the
funniest shame is just screaming people
thought it was me screaming well yes
because that would be appropriate I mean
that's that's to be expected from Tim
that's true yeah I just want to say I
know want to know more about this
receptacle where you put your emails for
Sheamus's site that sounds terrifying
I'm saying go to freedomtunes.com
t-o-o-n-s you'll be able to drop your
email address in there that receptacle I
am definitely gonna drink whiskey for
this episode so you have to show for
sure you guys can follow me on Twitter's
and twitters with the tweets and
minds.com at sour patchlands as well as
sour patchlands.me
all right thanks for hanging out
everybody we'll see you over at
timcast.com talking about lactating men